Okay...
Everybody!
Hello!
Hello, hello!
This is...
This is Uto and this is Ditto.
I'm meeting them for the first time.
Nice to meet you guys!
My new friends!
Yeah!
This is like...
How many times are Ditto and I gonna meet again?
This is my first time meeting you, Ditto.
Yeah!
This is my first time meeting you, Ditto and Uto!
Hello, welcome to...
the G -Rex rank!
We are the girl Pred squad!
All of us are like...
Pred!
Right, Uto?
You're Pred, right?
Uto, you...
You Pred player, right?
Yeah!
Wow!
What?
I'm a pro!
Yeah, Uto is a pro player.
She is actually the best player out of the three of us.
She got like rank one in season seven.
Yeah, Uto?
Yes, yes, yes!
Yeah, yeah!
She was rank one!
The pro player!
Yeah, so she carry us.
Right, Uto?
Uto carry?
Yeah!
Uto carry!
Yeah, please, please carry me too.
Yeah, carry me too.
Carry us.
Carry Ditto and I get twenty, twenty...
twenty kills 4k.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah!
I believe.
Yeah, yeah, guys.
It's good.
Okay, I'll die so I can watch you, Uto.
Okay, okay, okay.
Come on, come on!
Hey, yes.
Let's go, let's go.
Ditto has not slept a lot.
I'm not...
Actually, I just woke up.
She just woke up.
She went to bed at four in the morning.
Nice to meet you guys.
Also, how long we gonna play for?
As long as Uto wants.
Maybe ten hours.
Wait, okay, wait.
Maybe ten hours is not enough.
Yeah, you're right.
Maybe twelve hours?
Two streams.
Part two.
Yeah, maybe two streams.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should put another waiting room.
Yeah.
You like my tracker?
000?
Oh, your pet, your pet badge.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I have...
I know I have a pet badge now.
Okay, here we go.
Okay.
Where we landing Uto?
Don't worry.
I drank coffee.
Okay.
Jump, jump, jump.
You jump, jump.
Here.
Someone in my chat was like, Why is she playing Seer?
Cause Seer is meta!
Oh really?
Oh, meta?
Seer is...
You know how original Seer was really broken?
Mhm.
They changed it back.
So now he's like the original Seer.
One team.
Okay.
Alright.
No, no, no.
Okay.
Oh my god.
What the hell?
Uto got killed.
One down.
Over here.
Fuck.
I fucked the gap.
He's stunned.
No he's not.
Wait, under.
On me.
I got him.
Did you crack them?
Let me chew.
I got him.
Nice.
Easy.
Uto carry!
Oh, they're masters!
They're masters by the way.
I told you we're better.
Cause we're pred.
We are all pred.
Yeah, we're all pred.
We're better than Master Player.
Nice one.
Let's go.
I'm so lucky I got word.
Yeah, I got PK.
Yeah, this one.
So, sound check guy.
How's the volume?
How's the volume by the way for all of us?
Yeah, like sound.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is our sound okay guys?
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, oh, oh.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna go with them.
Okay, you go.
Where?
Where are you?
Knock, knock, knock.
Down, down, down.
Nice.
Uto, nice, Uto!
Nice!
Uto, three kill!
Three kill, Uto.
Nice, Uto.
Yeah!
My same.
Pro player!
Oh, yeah, that's for sure.
What the fuck?
How do they have so much loot?
They have so much loot.
What the hell?
Yeah, why?
I have like nothing here.
Me too.
Alright, ooh, R9.
Nice one.
Nice.
It's not that good.
Yeah, RE is so good now.
Really?
Why?
Yeah, because it's harder to get armor.
So, RE, Hammerpoint, plus Digi.
Hmm?
So, everyone...
RE 45 and Hammerpoint is so strong.
Um, did you say...
Yeah, cause Digi is now on pistol.
Crystal.
Oh yes, yes, yes.
So no SMG.
I see, I see.
Do I have anybody here?
Okay, I leave you guys.
If I die...
It's Uto's fault.
Don't let me die, Uto.
Uto, I'm coming.
I should scan too.
I need a cell.
You need a cell?
Here.
Yes.
Oh, where?
I have a hemlock.
Hemlock?
Yeah, hemlock.
Where?
Hemlock.
You want hemlock or you hear hemlock?
No, I will play hemlock.
Oh, okay.
I have hemlock right now.
Nice.
I hear...
I hear 30-30 is still strong.
Ah, 30-30?
Okay.
Yeah, 30-30, hemlock...
Flatline?
Yeah, flatline is strong.
And then short range is like RE45 now.
And vault.
Vault is always strong though.
Enemy scan.
Enemy scan?
Where?
Oh, yeah!
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
I... I...
I'm here.
K, K.
They know.
Whoa!
Go!
Here.
Almost K.
I see.
Oh.
Oh, hey, RE.
K, K, K.
Oh, on me, on me.
You here?
Oh, shit.
It's like K, it's K.
Behind us?
Flash, flash, flash.
Flash, flash?
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
I almost kicked one.
I'm coming, I'm coming over here.
Yeah!
Oh, no!
I'm dead.
Goodbye.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Yeah.
Pally.
Can't do it.
He's lit, he's lit.
He's lit, yeah.
Oh, no.
My shoe is broken.
My shoe is gonna bolt.
Okay.
No!
He shot me, dude!
I wanted to have a reset.
The Pally is so good!
Yeah, the Pally is...
I'm so sorry.
I shouldn't get a flat tire.
No!
You got father!
Okay.
I should have queued.
I get pinged!
Ping!
Oh my god.
We are warming up.
Warm up, warm up, warm up.
Let's warm up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Warm up until when?
We're not bad.
It was ping.
Okay, look.
Uto is playing with 300 ping.
Ditto is playing with 300 ping.
And I'm playing with 400 ping.
Right?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're all playing with really bad ping.
I'm just this one.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
Champion next game.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, like...
The number you see right now, that's not true.
I'm playing with 400 ping.
I'm playing with 300 ping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But we're so good.
Even when we have high ping, we're so good.
Yes.
Yeah, Uto...
She's a pro player, and she plays with 300 ping every day.
Yeah, and...
She's doing this game every week.
I saw it.
Yeah, you know right now, she's not playing with her monitor on.
Turn on your monitor.
Turn on your screen.
She plays with only sound.
Only sound.
Yeah.
Only ears.
Yeah, only ears.
She's so good.
Use your hands too.
Don't use your feet, okay?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, play with your hands, Uto.
Yeah, play with your hands.
I know you're really good.
That's why she's a pro.
The handle.
Okay, okay, okay.
Screen is on, hands on the mouse.
Uto, you can go anywhere.
Okay.
I'm getting a bit thirsty.
Yeah.
You're really low.
So low.
Are you getting up?
Who's that?
But you made it.
Yeah.
Well, well.
Anyone here?
Here.
I don't think I see anybody.
I think.
I see one team in countdown.
Oh, countdown?
Uto is going to kill them first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uto, you go countdown.
Go to countdown, Uto.
Countdown?
Yeah, go to countdown.
Kill them all.
We loot, you kill.
I got power.
Where are the enemies?
Oh, countdown.
Careful.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, you go now and then we loot.
Go!
I believe in you, Uto.
You're so strong.
It'll be white armor.
It'll be easy.
So easy.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going, I'm going, cheer.
Wait, you're going?
Okay, I'm looting.
I'm looting.
This is important.
We're fighting, we're fighting.
Okay, okay, okay.
You're pro at Pred.
You don't need me.
Oh, right, right, right.
We don't need you.
Yeah, one pro player can kill three people.
See?
You don't need me.
Oh, oh.
You, you.
Nice, Uto.
Nice.
See?
Why am I here?
Right here, right here, right here.
Right here, right here.
Oh, shit!
Oh, man.
Wait.
What?
Wait, wait.
Where?
Right, right.
Is this a dead body?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm ping, I'm ping, I'm ping.
What?
I'm banning, I'm banning.
Oh, I'm FBs.
Oh, okay.
On top, okay.
Maybe the last one?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm not sure.
I'm looking.
I don't see anybody in scan.
Oh, here, here.
What the fuck?
Almost hit, almost hit.
I'm running.
I'm late.
Come over.
Come, come, come.
Inside, inside.
Come over.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Right side, right side.
Where is he?
Did he run?
Here, yes.
Okay, I'm gonna loot.
You guys will be fine.
Okay, we can kill.
Shit.
You'll be fine.
You don't need me.
We can, we can.
You can kill them.
Loot is important.
Look at all this loot.
Are you still fighting?
Oh no, you killed them!
No, I thirsted.
No, no, no, no.
I thirst.
No one's dead.
You guys will be fine.
He's lucky.
It's okay.
We kill him again.
We just wanna go...
Let them live and we kill them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let them rest.
We won't get KP'd.
But we just wanna kill them.
You guys wanna...
Let's just take a fire scheme.
Yeah, let's go here.
Okay, I'm gonna scan the lane.
Oi!
Hey!
What?
Don't forget to pick up that wine.
Yeah, I'll go pick it up.
Okay, okay, okay.
Don't worry.
Let's upgrade our...
My army.
Yay!
Oh, upgrade.
My two.
Backpack?
I need the backpack.
Wait, what are you...
Oh, you have no backpack.
Okay.
No backpack.
Wait, wait, no.
Let's go to...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, nice.
I found it.
Wait, can I...
You already scanned ring, right?
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, you did.
Alright, let's go get vault.
Oh, there's people here.
Let's go.
Wait, wait.
Get vault first.
Vault.
Okay.
Yeah, because I have key.
I want better stuff.
I have no attack... I want hammer point.
I think they're fighting at staging.
Yeah, they are.
Okay, okay, vault, vault, vault.
I can't open the key.
Vault, vault, vault.
Open the vault.
Open.
Ooh.
Wow, wow, wow.
What is this?
Wow, I got everything.
Wow.
Wow, wow.
Okay.
Barrel?
Wow.
Is this hammer point?
Oh, it's skull piercer.
Okay.
Let's go kill.
Oh.
Oh, wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait.
Behind, behind, behind.
Look, look, look.
Behind us.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, let's see.
Okay, I wish to fly.
I see...
They're like this way.
No, no, no, no.
Yeah.
So close, so close to us.
Yeah, yeah.
There's...
It's split.
Split up.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, careful.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, what was that?
Behind you, behind you.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm so fucked.
I'm stunned.
Let me finish.
I'm dead.
No.
Oh, my God.
I got crimped.
I got stunned.
Okay.
All right.
Ditto, turn on your monitor.
Oh, my God.
I didn't see.
Say hi.
Ditto, turn on your monitor.
Okay.
I turn on my monitor.
I'm lady.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll turn on my monitor too.
I'll turn it on.
Okay.
I'm lady.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
All monitors turned on.
All right.
Okay.
Don't worry.
No more.
No more listening.
Just now we see.
Okay.
Do you think Bangalore is good?
Oh, Bangalore is good.
I heard Bangalore and Horizon is really good.
Horizon?
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
I play Horizon.
Bangalore, Horizon, Sierra, Bloodhound.
I heard we're really good.
I see.
Because like...
Bloodhound?
I'm Bloodhound.
Oh.
Because like his scans are better.
I don't remember his kit.
But like...
Okay.
What is this kit?
Oh, yeah.
The cooldown and stuff.
And then the gain 25 HP per knock.
Oh, Revenant is good too.
Revenant, Crypto is good too.
Sierra is good.
Everyone plays Sierra now.
Oh, no.
Are you Pred?
No, no, no.
You.
Oh, no.
I know.
I meant my chat.
My chat.
My chat was like, Sierra is not good.
I think Sierra is good.
The Earth is really weak.
His scan is better now.
Oh, really?
His scan?
Yeah.
Because like it's longer.
Oh.
Yeah.
I see.
Okay.
I will smoke and you guys scan and we win.
One team.
Oh, no.
Okay.
Oh?
No team.
Nice.
Whoa.
Put it.
Come on.
I want.
I want power.
Power.
I got power too.
Wow.
That's nice.
I like how we're all...
Okay.
In the same building.
Ooh.
Wait.
Is there a team of us?
Is there?
Wait.
I see no one.
No one?
Okay.
I'm going to look.
Is there anyone here?
Really?
No, no.
I mean any.
Is there?
No, no, no.
Okay.
I'm going out.
Yes.
All you guys.
And one team on Geyser.
One team on Geyser?
Okay.
My...
I'll get the Moby.
Two for...
Two for score.
Ooh.
Let's see.
Two for...
Oh.
I haven't found a single hammer point.
Is hammer point crafter?
No.
Wait.
It's bats.
There's no more crafter.
I forgot.
Yeah.
It's pretty hard to find.
I haven't found a single hammer point.
I will be when I find one.
Oh.
Okay.
I have like zero attachments on Prowler.
I need...
Let's see.
Okay.
I will go grab that one.
Oh.
We should do...
Wait.
Is that ring?
Consulate.
Oh.
Yeah.
Never mind.
That's...
That's map consulate.
Where are we...
Where do we...
Wait.
Who's IGL?
Uto.
IGL.
Me?
Yeah.
You're pro.
Okay.
Where?
Kill.
Kill?
Kill who?
Who do we kill?
Kill enemy.
Where?
Okay.
Kill Doki Forest.
Where enemy?
Oh.
Here.
Let's go.
Uhu.
Ukto goes first because...
Ukto kill.
Hahaha.
Ukto strongest.
Buzz to Brad.
Okay.
Alright.
MVP.
I'm not sure if they are finished.
I didn't hear anything.
I hear.
Just do.
Just do fighting.
Oh.
Okay.
Wtf?
Fabi.
Sorry, let me put it on right now.
Alright, headphones on.
Where?
No heartbeat.
Oh, big mod?
Okay.
They might have better armor.
Maybe.
I'm looking.
I have to get closer.
Maybe?
Her armor is pretty bad too.
I can't scan this.
I'm too far.
Yes.
Let me shake.
No heartbeats?
No heartbeat?
No?
Ditto!
Liar!
Wait, what?
Oh, so far!
Ditto, you liar.
One guy cracked.
You liar.
Oh!
I'm a liar!
You liar.
They rotate.
Yeah.
Rotate.
This is why Uto's idea.
Okay, Uto, Uto.
Orders, orders.
Wait, I think...
In ring, in ring.
Wait, wait, wait.
They're coming, they're coming.
Jump tower, jump tower.
Jump tower, yeah.
Oh, they flat.
Wait, wait, one...
Oh, they left, yeah.
Yeah, I will chase them.
Okay, I guess I'll jump tower.
I think they are...
Oh, I'm so far.
Where are they?
I'm so far.
They're like... They flew over this way.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ditto, what's wrong with your ears?
Why is your...
They're here.
They check me.
I pinged them.
Okay.
They're to my left.
Okay, kill them.
Kill, kill.
Alright.
Left side.
They're...
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're here, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, they're coming to us.
Maybe?
Are they?
They get inside.
Inside?
Oh, so they'll be... They're here then.
Yeah.
They have... They have spear?
I don't know.
Do they?
Yeah.
Ditto, put your headphones on.
It's sign, it's sign, sign, sign.
Look here, look here.
No?
Ditto!
No, look, look, look.
No, no.
No heartbeat.
I heard something.
Where?
There's nothing.
No.
Where?
No heartbeat.
I heard something.
No.
No enemy.
The teleport!
They left, right?
They...
Close the door.
I think they went that.
I think they went...
Oh.
Maybe they're here.
The hole is inside.
This is why...
This is why Uto's IGL.
Hahahaha.
IZF!
KURIN!
Okay...
KURIN...
Where, where, where?
The Toast, crazy.
The Toast...
The Toast, crazy!
What are we gonna do?
Go kill, go kill.
Go kill?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have... I have...
I have tower.
Okay, okay, okay.
I wait, I wait, I wait.
Wait, wait.
Near, near, near.
Oh, shit!
One down, one down.
Nice.
Okay.
One keg, one keg, one keg.
Is this yours?
Inside, inside, inside.
Oh, inside?
Okay.
Is this yours?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Going up then.
I have thirst.
Thirsted.
Okay, nice.
Here, this way.
This side?
Yep.
I think they run.
Oh.
Eh, enemy.
Oh, it's so low.
Left, left, left.
In front of me.
Oh my god, they...
They're lining.
He's right here.
He's scared.
Kill him.
Up, up, up, enemy.
Oh, on me, on me.
Okay.
Where?
Here.
He run, I think?
Wait.
Oh, heartbeat?
Heartbeat here, here, here.
Here, here, here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's another squad.
Yeah, new team, new team, new team, new team.
Okay, okay.
New team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
We have to go.
Okay, okay.
Going, going, going.
Yeah, we can go back, go back, go back.
Go back, go back, go back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't want fight in ring.
I hate fighting in ring.
Okay, me too.
Oh, the Levin is so fast.
I know.
That's so fast.
Rev is strong now.
Does he have good loot?
Where did you kill him?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, oh.
Yummy.
Oh.
I took everything.
Look at that.
We got it.
Uto, I chill.
Uto kill.
Ditto.
What happened, Ditto?
I'm smart.
No.
They shot me.
Genius.
I'm a genius.
I was gonna die.
Just don't die.
I'm not dead.
I'm still alive.
Okay, this is why Uto is the pro player and we are just pride.
Yeah, she not hold for us.
Yeah.
Yeah, we are just pride.
She pro.
This is how she got rank 1 in season 7.
Yeah.
Oh, rez?
Here, rez.
One team?
Maybe more than one.
Maybe more.
Yeah.
Let me check.
No heartbeat?
Anyone there?
No.
No heartbeat.
Okay.
So they are gonna come from right.
We could meet up.
Okay.
We can meet up here.
What the...
Oh!
That left.
I'm dying to the left.
On me.
Okay.
Enemy?
Heartbeat.
Okay.
To my right.
I hear... Yeah.
Two.
Two enemy.
Yeah.
They rez.
Go.
Kill me.
He's... He's stunned.
He's stunned.
Very low.
Yeah.
Bloodhound low.
Got him?
Nice!
Where's your teammate?
Eh?
Looking for heartbeat?
No heartbeat.
They left.
That left.
Yeah.
Die to the lane.
Aww.
Wow.
Friend.
Where's your friend?
Yeah.
Friend.
He's not family.
I think maybe he's like...
here somewhere.
Like they walk around.
Okay.
I think.
I...
I get up.
Yeah.
I think he's...
They ran around.
Wow.
I would never leave you guys like them.
Where should we go?
Where should we go now?
I wanna see... find the knock guy.
Oh here!
Enemy!
Go.
Kill.
Oh dead.
I'm dead.
Nice.
See?
Good idea.
Nice idea.
Okay.
I... I...
I will shut my mouth and I will leave.
Enemy.
New.
Oh.
Help me.
We're coming over.
We're coming.
Oh wait.
Four?
Here.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Red armor.
My aim.
That.
Was pretty bad there.
Inside.
Behind?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Let's.
Let's go for this.
Oh wait.
Wait.
One team is me.
Fuck.
No.
One team is me.
Oh shit.
Nice.
I'm going 2x.
Can you call on me?
Wait.
That's Vigi.
Oh.
We're so fucked.
I'm gonna.
I'm going to.
Wait.
This is ring 4.
Oh shit.
Okay.
This is scary.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
Maybe I can revive Uto.
I think.
Yeah.
Uto can you crawl to me?
Uto can you crawl?
Yeah.
Keep crawling.
And you can revive me here.
Okay.
Alright.
Goodbye Uto.
Goodbye.
Wait.
Are you okay, Tera?
I'm okay.
That one team there.
But I think that's.
It's fine.
It's fine?
Is it actually fine?
You can revive me here.
Okay.
Yes.
Be careful.
I swear to god.
If you're not fine.
Liar.
I'm fine.
Are you sure?
You're.
Okay.
One team here.
No.
I'm not fine.
Okay.
Let's go.
Alright.
I don't.
I don't think I was fine.
No.
Why?
Every time.
I was not fine.
I was.
He has an army.
Yeah.
I'm playing Bangla.
Okay.
Nice.
Nice call.
Okay, this time.
This time we'll get champion.
Right here.
I believe.
I believe this time.
It'll be different.
There's no sound.
I turned on my headphones but there's no sound behind me.
Are you sure?
Are you sure it did help?
Yes.
I'm sure.
Is your headphones on correctly?
Okay.
Yeah.
Wait.
Did you turn Apex sound on?
This is why we need to play for 12 hours.
We always take two hours for warm up.
Yeah.
We need two hours to warm up.
Okay.
Let me turn off my VPN.
I'm turning off my VPN.
This time.
NordVPN off.
Not sponsored.
Let's go.
I'm not in the banner.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
Why did it mute you guys?
What?
It muted you guys.
Wow.
Alright.
Where are we landing?
Countdown?
No.
Here.
Countdown?
Come on.
Yeah.
Here.
We can do it.
Look at us.
Oh.
Is this the place?
Okay.
Don't worry.
We're prepped.
No.
They're on the way.
Don't worry.
There's no one of us.
One team.
Yeah.
One team is just one team.
We're so good.
I have a Mozambique.
I'm not good.
One guy with me.
One team is me.
I'm not.
I have Mozambique.
Mozambique.
Okay.
You can do it.
You're prepped.
You're prepped too.
You're also prepped.
You can.
But Uto is pro.
Come here.
You're both Uto.
Uto.
Come here.
Pro.
We need pro.
You say.
Okay.
Two teams.
Only one team.
One guy is there.
Okay.
We're inside the next room.
I see them.
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
Alright.
They can aim.
They're pro.
They're pro too.
I'm going to heal myself.
I need to heal.
No sound.
No.
He's streamered mode.
He is pro.
Dude.
I'm gonna come to you.
No sound.
So at least we'll be together.
Wait, two teams?
Two teams?
Yeah, two teams.
On me?
Actually?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Wait!
What?
I thought it was...
New team, new team.
Another new team!
Another new team, yeah.
Wait, they are bread!
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
New team.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
We were... look.
Look.
That game we were trolling.
We were trolling.
Look, only Preds can kill Preds, okay?
Okay, okay.
They're Pred, so they killed us too.
If it was not Pred players, you know, they're higher Pred ranked.
than us.
Yes, yes.
Okay, okay.
And they are poor because they killed Utho.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They had two Pros.
We only have one.
Guys, we only have one.
Only have one.
We only have one Pro.
It's not fair.
They had two Pros.
Do you wanna be a PoI?
No.
I want to have a life.
I want...
Alright.
Conduit can use Q like two times.
Oh, true, true.
True!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's pretty strong, I think.
We'll be so strong.
Yeah.
True.
We can't die.
Okay.
If we die, it's Utho's fault.
Oh!
Oh my god, they have a roller player.
They have two roller players.
It's over.
I think everyone in this is over.
Why did you get the silver?
We could have been in bronze!
No!
My game crashed!
Game crashed!
No!
Don't drop yet!
Where's my steam?
No, we are learning!
No!
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
Let's go somewhere else.
Okay, okay.
I'm coming back.
Epic Center.
Don't worry.
I'm loading in.
It's okay.
You guys can watch V3.
I believe you.
Just don't land on another pred.
Just don't...
Don't land on a protein!
Yourself.
The protein behind... near us.
Wait, what?
I said don't!
I said don't land on a protein!
Okay, okay.
I'm here.
I'm okay.
Okay, nice, nice!
Nice!
I'm okay now.
Okay, Where is team?
Where's enemy?
Okay.
Enemy can go kill them.
Yeah, we'll be fine.
Okay, I'm heading over.
I have loot.
I'll head over to Ditto.
Okay.
Oh!
There's two.
Is it one team or two?
Only one team.
I have 30-30.
I can poke.
Nice.
I'm looking.
Okay.
I'm charging my ult.
I don't see them.
Okay.
It's looted on the right side.
There's loot here too.
I don't see them.
Oh, digi, digi.
Oh, I see, I see, I see, I see.
Here.
Oh, digi.
I don't have...
Push?
Push.
Okay, okay.
Uta says push.
Oh, yeah, they're here.
I see them.
They're on the right.
Okay, okay.
I mean, we can...
We can take this.
Yes, take the zip line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You might hear it though.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
He's separating.
His teammates are to the right.
Okay.
I'm going to ditto.
I see one of them.
I don't know where he is.
Inside, inside, inside.
One or two?
Only one.
Here?
Where?
On me?
I hear him.
Up, up, up.
Up two, up two.
Two?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three, three.
Three?
All three.
Okay.
All three?
Then they'll know we're here.
They know.
Wait.
Are they shooting you?
Yeah, okay.
I don't know if we could get to...
I don't know if we can climb up.
I don't know if that's smart.
Yeah.
I don't think...
Oh!
Goodbye, Uto.
Okay.
On me, on me?
On me, on me, on me?
On.
Oh, shit!
No!
Fall!
Goodbye, Tito.
Oh my god!
On me!
Dang it!
Fall!
That was like...
Okay, wait.
I got it.
Guys, no.
I figured it out.
I should be playing Mad Maggie.
No, I...
I know now.
Now we win.
What is... What is Mad Maggie's kid?
I don't even know.
Now, this time.
This time.
We were just trying to find the best team comp.
You know?
We don't know what the best team comp is.
Alright, what is...
Okay.
What is the best team comp?
Mad Maggie.
Really?
No, I don't know.
No!
Her pose is good, I think.
I think her ball is really good though.
Yeah.
This is it.
This time.
Okay.
I believe.
Good luck!
Okay.
What is my thing?
True.
The extra drill charge.
Ooh, big drill!
Holy shit!
That's insane.
We're just downloading right now.
Downloading meta.
Every game we play, we get better.
We're like AI.
Yeah, yes, yes, yes, yes.
We're AI learning right now.
We're AI.
Yeah, chat GPT.
Every game we get stronger.
We're like AI.
Is there a team here?
Nice.
Yeah, one team here.
Where?
With you.
Oh, shit!
Yeah!
Yeah, with me, with me by the way.
Let me...
Okay, are you okay?
I'm okay, I'm okay.
He's like in here.
One team here.
Two?
Is this two teams?
Maybe this...
Are they...
The same team.
They're the same team.
There's teaming countdown too.
Where are they?
Inside?
Yeah, inside.
GB!
Kill him!
Ok, ok.
I'm over.
One crack.
GB!
High ground?
Yeah, high ground.
Don't fall.
On me?
What the fuck?
What?
I got beamed so fast!
What the fuck?
It's ok.
I beamed them too.
What?
Holy shit!
That was so fast!
I forgot what it was like to have zero armor.
Oh no, they're resing.
Ok, whoever that guy that killed me...
Fuck that guy.
I'm gonna go.
Careful, careful.
You guys can back up, I feel like.
Maybe just res me over the farther side.
Yeah, that's just smart.
Oh my god!
Bro, fuck that one guy.
Literally looked at him and I died.
Forgot.
Ok, ok.
And they're gonna come to us and we fight and we win.
Come here.
Careful, Uto.
Ok.
Oh no, she don't have to be careful.
She's poor.
Oh yeah, you're right.
You don't have to be careful.
You'll be fine.
Ok, fuck that!
Ok, oh shit.
One crack, one crack, one crack.
One crack?
Ok, I'm coming over.
I need to... I'm gonna get high ground.
Cause I'm scared now.
Are they?
Um...
You know?
Middle, middle, middle.
Oh, middle.
Oh my god.
Fuck that guy.
I don't have...
Long range.
Me too.
I will go get our army.
Yeah, in front of me.
I'm gonna go get Ditto.
We won't be together.
No, I can't.
After that guy, I'm just scared now.
I don't have...
A backpack.
You still don't... Wait, me too.
I still don't have a backpack.
Wait, there's a blue armor here.
Not blue, a blue helmet.
I need a two-cells.
There's no armor.
Where are they?
Are they still there?
I don't know.
I'm scared now.
No, I don't see one.
I don't see one.
Maybe they low-chained.
Yeah, that one guy gave me PTSD.
Oh my god, he beamed you.
Yeah.
I'm gonna give you two.
I lived for one second.
Wait a minute.
Two battle here.
Ooh.
Nice, nice, nice.
I think they...
They run?
We're already in ring.
Why do they need to go in ring when we're already in ring?
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
Let's go, Pizu.
Ooh.
I thought this was the other one.
Okay.
How did I still not...
How did I still not found a backpack?
I have zero shield cells.
Zero?
Okay.
Here, I'll sell.
Oh, nice.
Ooh.
Yummy.
Oh, it can...
It can fly to the core.
Wait.
They scanned.
Yo, they're still there.
Revenge.
Um, okay.
You guys kill that one guy that killed me.
And then I'll...
And then I'll be fine.
I need that.
Oh.
Where are they?
Still on the building.
Are they hiding?
Yeah.
This is I play.
There's a lot of team hiding.
Really?
Cowards.
Oh, they went there.
They went there.
Oh, okay.
They're fine.
That's fine.
Um...
I don't have shield cells.
Do you need valet?
No, I just need shield cells.
I only have two.
Okay.
I can give you tea here.
I'm gonna check if there's any extra here.
Thank you.
It's okay.
I will probably take it.
Alright.
There's a three... Does anyone want 3x?
Crypto drone?
Crypto?
Oh, here.
Here.
Oh, shit.
Over here?
Where?
I will go get here.
I will go to this building.
Over.
Where I'm looking at.
Jesus Christ.
He's cracked.
Okay.
I have to heal.
Alright.
Oh, that is them.
That's Yippie.
Nice.
Wait.
What?
Near me.
Near.
Near?
Yeah.
Near.
Okay.
I have to get them.
Near us.
Near.
Yeah.
Oh.
Backed up.
Two teams.
Careful.
I'm gonna go to Ditto.
I wanna be here.
Okay.
Hey, that's my body.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Careful, Ditto.
Yeah.
Go with...
Be careful.
Yeah.
Go high ground.
Okay.
Uh.
Careful.
Behind us.
Okay.
Um.
I will go fourth floor.
Hey, guys.
Pretty...
Yeah.
Pretty scary.
Okay.
Let's switch teams.
Scary.
I might die.
I might do something stupid.
Finally, I get blue.
That's fine.
I...
I... I wanna... I wanna fight the team behind us.
Uh.
They're like all the way.
I think we should get crack first.
Cause they're...
Yeah.
This team is so annoying though.
I'm burning one.
Yeah.
But you guys have shield cells?
Um.
I have G.
Yeah.
I need shield.
You're so poor.
Okay.
I... Okay.
I can give you one.
You're so poor.
That... That team is still white.
White armor.
Leave us alone.
I don't wanna waste my heals.
Okay.
I'll use my battery all...
Leave us alone.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Did he fuck this...
Oh my god.
Let us loot.
I wanna loot.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
Let us loot.
Leave.
Oh my god.
There's a crypt... Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm batting.
It's fine.
Bro.
Fuck this crypto drone.
What the heck.
Why they shoot us?
Yeah.
Fuck you guys.
That's my...
Fuck you.
Give me your charge.
Another new team.
There's so many new teams.
Yeah.
Is zone ending here?
I think zone's ending here.
Why is there so many teams?
Yeah.
Leave
us alone.
Leave.
Wait.
No.
Fighting.
Third party.
We can third this.
Oh shit.
Okay.
There's a team.
We can third this if we want to.
Are we gonna go third?
Do we want to?
We can.
Hi.
I'm GL.
We have no...
Third or no.
Wait.
That's fourth party.
Fourth party coming.
Okay.
There's a lot of teams.
We don't have anything.
We should...
We should go.
Yeah.
We should.
Get loot.
Go.
We should.
We have like nothing.
Wait.
Oh fuck.
No.
I fucked up.
Oh no.
Come.
They're still fighting.
We got loot here.
We can loot this box for loot.
Scan.
What the...
What?
Oh my god.
There's people here.
There's a ref here.
Oh my god.
Leave.
I'm Phoenix Kitting.
No.
Careful.
I'm helping.
Use your shield.
I'm...
Oh.
That... Fuck.
Okay.
I have to... I have to bat.
I have to bat.
Nice one.
No.
What?
Ayo is aiming.
Look.
We had nothing.
We were so poor.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
We couldn't loot.
Leave us alone.
Okay.
They didn't let us loot.
Yeah.
I had zero shields.
What do I do?
I just... I just wanted...
I just wanted heals.
We were so poor.
It was so sad.
Oh my god.
No one...
No one wanted us to get anything.
That's so fucked up.
There were three teams in Skyhook.
And...
There was five teams.
More teams kept coming.
We couldn't go anywhere.
Oh my god.
That one building had like three teams that ran in.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
We are in the middle of...
Of the lane.
No.
Of the team.
Yeah.
Like in the middle.
Oh my god.
That was like crazy.
Alright.
I'm muted but I want to say for those who are like hide your map.
If you...
If you cannot fucking see...
If you need a map to know where I am...
There's no way you can kill me.
Okay.
I got it.
You're not at skill level to kill me.
If you need a map to know where I am.
It's not that good.
Okay.
We're good.
Brawler.
I have an alternating.
Okay.
I have alternating massive.
I have a rampage.
And a two-way.
Wait.
Do we have team here?
No, right?
No.
We're the countdown team.
We are...
We are the countdown team.
Yeah.
There's a lot of team in Skyhook.
Alright.
Let's do it.
We're the third party.
Okay.
We can do it.
Whoa.
Okay.
That was a weird lag.
Are you lagging?
No.
I'm good.
I was lagging a little earlier.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'm good.
Let's go.
If you find hammer point, let me know.
Okay.
What are you using?
RE Hemlock.
Okay.
I'll grab some ammo.
Yeah.
Nice.
Are you guys ready?
I'm ready.
Let's go.
Let's see.
Hello.
Oh, I hear...
They're fighting.
Go.
Are you here?
I think.
They're a lot closer.
Yeah.
No knocks?
Right in front of me.
Another team shooting?
Three teams.
In this building too.
In this building?
Yeah.
Three teams?
Wait.
Someone near you, Utho.
Yeah.
On Utho.
Come to me.
I ulted.
On you.
Oh, we have to help Utho.
Help Utho.
I'm going.
I got one.
Oh my god.
He's low.
Where?
Above.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh.
I'm dead.
Ah, fuck.
Okay.
One guy here.
On the stairs.
Dreadfall.
Two guys.
I know.
I can't.
I'm really low.
You can go back to countdown and carve us.
Oh yeah.
Maybe.
If they don't push me.
Kill me.
Okay.
They might chase me though.
So.
Oh my god.
That's our star.
Yeah.
You guys died so fast.
What the fuck happened?
Yeah.
Like I got one creep.
I only have 9-9.
I made a perfect aim with my 9-9.
But I still lose.
Oh.
Cause you're on R9.
That's why.
You forgot.
R9 is useless.
I don't have...
I don't have another camera than R9.
Is alternator better than R9?
R-E?
Alternator.
Alternator?
I mean.
I don't know.
I just know...
R9 is so dog shit now.
Yes.
That's all I know.
Alright chat.
Okay.
Apex players and chat.
Which one is better?
Alternator or...
I think like alternator gives more damage.
I feel like.
Yeah.
I feel like that.
Especially if you have...
Oh.
They come.
They're coming.
Where?
Ping?
Here?
Yeah.
I see them.
On the bridge too.
80?
I'm trying to help you guys.
Okay.
I'm up.
Hello.
I see them.
They're to my left.
I cracked the Waxxon.
The Waxxon is running.
To your left here.
But the Waxxon is here.
So it's one.
Waxxon is far from team.
But careful of...
Careful.
I'm coming up.
Almost cracked.
Cracked.
Two here.
Okay.
I might run.
Yeah.
I'm gonna run.
Uto.
I was like.
No!
See you.
Oh my god.
What the f***?
That's so fast.
Oh what the heck.
I think my ear.
My ear stayed.
What happened?
I didn't hear anything.
Dero.
You can like sometimes.
You hear the.
You hear like the smallest things.
Or you hear nothing.
Yeah.
What the heck.
Like.
There are two.
Two people on my left.
But I couldn't hear anything.
When I realize it.
I think you're getting old.
You're getting old.
No.
I was just 17.
You're cute.
No.
You're getting old.
Okay.
It's time.
It's time for me to.
Okay.
I will use my ear this time.
You.
Yes.
I forgot.
I turned on my headphone.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Guys.
This time.
This time it will be different.
We swear.
Yeah.
Don't worry.
Can't do it.
Is like.
How many excuses are we gonna have?
We're too heavy for Uto.
Tero.
We got him.
What?
We're too heavy for her.
Yeah.
We're too heavy.
Uto.
Please boost us.
Let's go.
Uto.
Boost us.
I'll give you five dollars.
Uto.
No more.
Okay.
Six dollars.
One membership.
I'll give you one.
One dollar.
What the fuck, Tero?
That was my house.
No.
This is mine.
What the fuck?
This is why we're too heavy for her.
I like boys.
This is why we're too heavy.
Okay.
Let's see.
I got 199 again.
Get rid of that.
Maybe car would be better.
Okay.
I can't say that.
But I won...
Pally.
Pally?
I found a lot of cars.
I haven't found a single hammer point.
Look.
Where the fuck are the hammer points?
There is hammer points.
But it's pretty...
Not now.
But I have ever seen hammer points.
Yeah.
Hammer point is...
I haven't found one hammer point yet.
Hammer lock.
Nice.
I'm gonna go open this bin.
Open this bin.
Okay.
If I don't...
If I don't find power, I will give you guys...
I'm gonna say I can find power too.
PK here.
You know, our first game was our best game.
What happened to us?
Our first game, we killed so many people.
Yeah.
What happened to us?
Maybe...
Maybe we have to...
Turn on hacks?
Don't worry.
While hacks on?
Don't worry, guys.
This time...
Oh, I forgot to turn it on.
Now I remember.
Okay.
I have so many cells now.
I see there's people here.
Okay, use power.
Okay, I got power.
Nice.
Oh, there's people landed here.
Okay.
Here.
Wait, there's two teams.
We can third party.
Okay.
Are you gonna get up?
I'm gonna...
Whoa.
That scared me.
I'm gonna...
They're fighting.
I'm hiding over.
Okay.
I see them.
Are you fighting?
I think they got knocks.
Did they finish already?
No.
Not yet?
No, no, no.
Still fighting.
Go.
Okay.
I'm so fast.
You're so fast.
I'm slowly.
Low, low, low, low.
Okay.
I'm going up.
I used my ult.
Mommy?
I knocked myself.
What?
It is your ult.
Oh my god.
You ult me.
I knocked you.
Guys.
They ran away.
They ran away?
Yeah.
Last guy.
That has to be last guy.
Flash, flash, flash.
Got him.
There's one more team.
Okay, okay.
I got confused.
Accident.
Accident?
Yeah.
Okay.
I know.
This is why we keep losing.
I don't play.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I am trying my best.
Okay.
Nice ult.
We won.
Did we not win?
No.
Okay.
We are going to win.
Wait.
What?
You got this.
Go, go, go.
Nice.
See?
So easy.
Okay.
Nice.
What a game.
See?
Even if I ult you, we still won.
Okay?
Okay.
So this team, we can win.
Yeah.
It's all about...
I just need to ult you again and then we win.
Oh no.
Peace.
No.
Anyone want to battle?
Yeah, I have five.
Okay.
How about you, Toh?
Battle?
Does anyone want these?
Okay.
I have six.
I will give you two.
Purple stock and...
Oh, actually I'll take that.
Purple stock and barrel stabilizer.
Does anyone want that?
Me.
I'm gonna...
You want to scan again?
Can I scan?
Yeah.
You want to scan again?
Yeah, it's all.
You can scan.
Yeah.
Scan here.
Nothing?
What the?
Right here.
This one.
Scan.
Right here.
Someone please give her GPS.
Yeah.
GPS.
Maybe that's why we're losing.
Alright.
Okay.
I see.
She was gonna go there.
Oh, Lava.
Lava is a lot.
I feel like he's gonna be...
Oh my god.
We're so sure.
See?
There's no one near us.
Yeah.
There's a team here.
Where should we go?
I feel like...
Look at the Lava.
Okay.
Lava.
Go there.
Yeah.
Might as well.
Or we go here and then kill this team.
Oh, this way?
Okay.
Yeah.
Cause they have to come to us.
Okay.
Oh, big drill.
Alright.
We can do this.
If not champion, top 3.
Okay.
Top 3.
I'm... This game.
Come on.
Do you don't need champion?
This game.
No.
Okay.
This game.
You changed your mind so fast.
Look.
We were not lucky for...
Okay.
We are not lucky.
You see anybody?
I'm watching.
I'm looking.
I see no one.
I don't see anyone yet.
I don't see anybody.
Are they gonna come to us?
They should.
Far.
Let's see.
Is there any scans here?
No, there isn't.
Okay.
I mean, we could... They have to come here.
Yeah, but...
I have no clue.
Where are they?
They could... They go here or here.
Or tunnels.
Yeah.
Let's just wait.
But if they...
If they went to landslide, they will...
They would meet another...
Yeah.
Squad.
That's true.
We could...
Why am I the only one who...
Who have blue armor?
Because you don't shoot your gun?
No, I shoot it.
Because you should have ulted at your teammates.
No, I know.
Because I got your ult.
Yeah.
But I got purple though.
I ulted you and I got purple.
Really?
Yeah.
That's how it works.
If you ult at me, you get purple.
I see.
Okay.
I have to ult at you.
Yeah.
Maybe I might get late army.
Oh, yeah.
True.
Oh, here.
Right in front of me.
Almost kicked.
I didn't hit anything, by the way.
Oh my god.
Purple armor.
Yeah.
Purple and red.
Guys, I don't know.
I don't feel so good.
They have purple armor.
Wait.
No.
We have purple.
You single.
Oh, they are taking jump tower.
What are we gonna do?
Just shoot it.
They might walk up.
I think they will walk up.
Yeah.
The jump pad.
The jump pad?
Okay.
Yeah.
Did you jump pad?
I don't see them.
Are they coming over?
Two over.
One lane.
Yeah.
They are coming down.
Behind the rock.
Okay.
One of us is caked.
The guy on the line is lying.
Whoa!
Watch out.
Almost cracked him.
Cracked him?
Regular cracked.
Last guy.
Help.
Hold though.
Do you have Q?
Yeah.
Behind you.
Here.
Nice.
Nice one.
Look.
We did it.
We win.
Top three.
Okay.
No.
I'm top three.
Don't jinx it.
Okay.
Top three.
Don't jinx it.
No.
Top three.
Oh, shit.
Eva 8.
I'm gonna grab the Eva 8.
I heard Eva 8 is so strong.
Yeah.
Eva 8 is so strong.
Last time I played Eva 8, I hit Nazi.
So I stopped it.
I stopped playing.
That's not good.
Okay.
Maybe we can go from the right side?
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
Maybe top three.
Someone's dying.
Top three.
Stop it.
Oh, shit.
That's what's in here.
Who's hiding?
Oh, Eva.
Oh, you are.
You can play.
I thought I had...
I have Eva already.
Get the Eva.
It's so strong.
How about two Eva?
Two Evas?
Okay.
You know what?
Two Evas.
Let's go.
I'll do it.
I met Maggie anyway.
Yeah.
Do it.
The territory is... Top three.
Let's go.
Top three.
Top two.
Wait.
Scan.
We can scan.
Oh, wait.
No.
We can't.
Never mind.
No scan.
No.
Okay.
Are they fighting?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, my sky is so low.
Where?
Keep paying.
Over here.
I only have close range.
I have another...
Another one there.
I will take... I will go chase...
Please.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
Behind.
Oh, behind.
Here.
Under the pole.
Yeah.
The second team is all over there.
I feel like... Wait.
We're in middle.
We should go back.
Okay.
We go back.
Yeah.
Wait.
Let's see.
Where is good?
Over there?
There's a team there.
Isn't it?
Is there a team there?
Where can we go?
We're in the middle right now.
No.
We're in... Oh, okay.
We can stay here.
It's okay.
Yeah.
We'll stay here.
There's...
We're... We're in between two teams.
Yeah.
Another team there.
One team there and one team on the left side.
Guys.
I have Eva 8.
What do I do?
You only have Eva 8.
We can... We can do it.
I can't do it.
Okay.
They have to... Make them push me.
It's like a run.
Okay.
I can't die.
If I die, they get two Eva 8s.
They did it.
That's too scary.
I don't want...
Oh, wow.
They have Horizon.
They're over here?
Yeah.
What the f***?
They're coming.
They're coming?
What are they doing?
Stop.
We're gonna get third.
It's... Leave.
Leave.
What are you doing?
Someone make sure we don't get third.
Someone make sure we don't get third party.
I'm gonna make sure.
Okay.
Someone look right... I'll look behind.
I'll look behind.
Yeah.
I don't wanna get thirded.
Where's the second team?
Yeah.
My aim is so good.
I see the second team over here.
Okay.
Horizon takes...
Are they trying to push us?
It's fine.
We have here.
No, it's fine.
They can't.
Yeah.
No.
Behind the log.
Alright.
Team here and...
And then team here.
Okay.
We wait.
They push us.
Oh, s***.
How many people on the left side?
I don't know.
I think there's two.
Maybe.
I'm lucky on my right.
Okay.
We wait.
Until zone is small.
So I can...
So I can eva-ate.
Yeah.
Nice.
I think they... I feel like they're gonna push us.
I think they...
I feel like they're gonna push us.
It's okay.
This is our team.
They push each other.
We have...
We have zone.
It's fine.
Okay.
Yeah.
We wait.
We can be patient.
Okay.
Yeah.
We wait.
We have Horizon and Bangalore.
Horizon stood behind the log.
Here.
He ran up here.
I see him.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I saw it.
I'm looking my left right now.
Right here.
Okay.
Are you trying to... You look right.
Yeah.
You look this team.
I look the left team.
Okay.
Come on.
Get out of here.
I want them to fight.
Wait.
Go get out of here.
What?
Come here.
Get over here.
Boom.
Yeah.
It's so scary, isn't it?
My Eva A.
Yeah.
Make them fight each other.
Nice.
I think it's... I don't know if that's one guy.
No.
That's two.
It's two.
No.
There's a guy right here.
Below me.
Okay.
They have Horizon.
Maybe they might...
They're below me.
I need help.
Wow.
Below me.
Below me too.
Push.
No.
They're not pushing.
They might push.
They might push now.
Yeah.
I'm backing up to you, Ditto.
To get here.
I'm coming.
I'm coming to you.
Be careful.
I'm behind the log.
Okay.
Anyone have energy?
Nope.
I mean, I have some.
I have some.
I have some here.
Okay.
I hit one.
Almost hit one.
I'm coming over.
We have to be careful.
I'm giving you armor.
Yeah.
Okay.
Two.
Yeah.
Get away from us!
Leave!
I'm backing up.
Careful, Ditto.
Careful.
You're here.
Oh no.
Wait.
Behind us.
Oh shit.
Behind.
No!
Why are you there?
Behind us!
Hide!
Ditto!
No!
Okay, they're fighting each other.
They're fighting each other.
We're going down.
Go go.
Wait.
I'm safe.
I'm trying to go down.
It's fine.
Just chill.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Come here.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh my god!
Why are they all on us?
They don't fight each other!
My two evil aides!
I told you, top three!
I told you!
They don't fight each other!
Why us?
We said babies!
Okay, this time.
This time?
This time.
See, I told you, top three!
Top three!
If we say champion, we might get champion.
Okay, okay.
Top two.
Oh my god, they were scared of my evil aide!
They are so scared!
Oh my god.
You have two evil aides.
My evil aides.
Oh my god, I don't know you!
I can't do anything!
Everyone was so far!
Evil aides!
Imagine if you have another gun.
And we might win that fight.
Yeah, if I had another gun that's not 2 evil aides.
Yeah.
I believed you're right.
Only they use 2 evil aides.
It's my fault.
That was fun.
He was 16.
Okay.
Yeah, it was stupid.
It was actually very stupid.
So yeah, I believe in us.
We're in silver.
We're in bronze.
We don't lose anything if we die.
Yeah.
Oh, I lost...
You're in silver!
Silver doesn't matter.
It's not that much.
Yeah, exactly.
No one retards.
But it does.
Okay, nice.
I'm surr- I still have no hammer point.
Where the fuck is the hammer point?
I don't see any hammer point.
Yeah.
I haven't seen one either.
Wait, I would've won if I had a third evil aide.
If I could...
If I was the...
What was his name?
The old man with 3 evil aides.
I would've won.
Oh, yeah.
Ballistic, yeah.
If I was ballistic, it would be 3 Eva 8s.
3 Eva 8s.
Yeah, 3 Eva 8s ballistic.
Oh my god, alright, alright, alright.
That's what I... That's why I didn't win that fight.
Okay, I want power and nemesis.
Nemesis.
Power and nemesis.
I have...
Nemesis, uh, RE.
Okay, I'm gonna run 30-30.
Anyone want this?
Run!
Yeah, I do.
I'm coming over.
Okay.
I swear, I haven't seen a single hammer point.
It's been...
It's been like...
Oh, like an hour and a half.
No hammer point.
I'm so sad.
Life... Life is horrible.
Life is not fair.
Life is not fair?
Yeah.
I don't get it.
Where is my...
Where is my hammer point?
Hammer point?
I don't see one.
Let me see.
Hammer point.
I don't see hammer point.
Where is...
There's a prowler.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe it's our comp.
We need to find the perfect comp.
Enemy.
Oh?
We're coming.
I'm coming.
Where?
Here?
Yeah, here.
High ground one.
Okay.
Yeah, on the high ground.
Revenant and Bloodhound.
Okay.
I see them.
Tracked.
Nice.
Nice?
I'm going, I'm going.
Careful.
I'm looking.
Okay.
I'm out.
Alright.
I'll come over to you.
High ground.
Oh, fuck.
I might be...
Oh, I'm good.
I'm good.
I'm okay.
Nice.
I knocked one.
On me, on me, on me.
Oh my god.
He fucking ran at me.
Careful, careful.
I'm helping.
On you, on you, on you.
No, no, no.
I'm on the ground.
Hey, last guy.
Last guy.
Yeah.
Woo.
Ta-dah.
Later.
He's so much better.
Yeah, fuck you.
Go back to Sylvie with us.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Let's go.
Let's go, guys.
Okay, I have to heal first.
Hammer point.
No hammer point.
Nice.
No point.
No hammer point.
I'm gonna slow heal.
I don't wanna waste my medkit.
Yeah they did.
Oh that rev.
That was so scary.
Yeah that rev was... You know what?
Now I know.
I need to play rev.
If I play rev... You gonna play rev?
If I play rev champion...
It's cause I wasn't on rev.
Do we have any beacons?
What did they buff, Liv and Ann?
Nothing.
I don't know.
I don't know but rev seems strong.
Which one...
Where do we go?
Futo, where do we go?
Futo.
Epicenter.
Yeah yeah yeah.
We have scanner too.
We can see a scan here first!
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
We forgot.
Sorry our monitors are turned off again.
Let me shake, let me shake.
Where are people?
Nobody.
Oh, here!
Wait.
Here, one team!
Oh!
Near us.
Yeah, yeah.
They know us.
No...
That's what?
Pathfinder?
Pathfinder and what was that?
Wraith?
Okay, I'm heading over.
Okay.
They're still looting.
Okay, I'll walk over.
If I die, I might die.
If you die, I... I...
You clutch.
I land.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You clutch.
Okay.
You clutch, remember.
If I die, Uto crush.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So...
It's good, it's good, it's good.
Inside, inside?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Octane almost kicked through army.
Yeah, there's one guy below us.
Over there?
Yeah.
Careful of under.
Whoa!
Okay, I'm backing out a little.
I'm backing out.
Be careful, they might grapple.
They might zip.
Careful.
Okay.
Healing?
I'm gonna... I'm gonna do this so they don't come out.
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I missed.
Oh, careful.
Scan.
Nice scan.
Maybe one guy might... so close to us.
Be careful, be careful.
I need a shield cell.
Oh, I hear them beside me.
They might... Oh, here.
Below me.
Right here.
Octane, crush.
Careful, careful.
Uto, heal, heal.
Scan, scan.
Heal Uto.
Under, under, under.
I knocked one, I knocked one.
Knocked one?
Okay, I'm coming over.
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ready?
I need help, though.
I'm back, I'm still... Oh, no.
Oh, so low, so low.
I can't, I can't.
Oh.
Another team, another team, another team.
Another team?
Okay, I'm backing, I'm backing up.
Yeah.
Careful here.
Behind, in front of you.
Yeah.
This is bad.
Careful.
Oh.
What, where are you guys?
Oh, we're going to get out of here.
Okay, okay.
Be honest.
I know, I know.
I have to leave, I have to leave.
We're fighting each other.
Yeah.
I'm doing some acting, guys.
There's no point in fighting this.
Somebody kill me.
Someone kill me.
Please.
There's no one.
There's someone saw me.
Crawl to them!
Why?
Keep ignoring me!
Crawl to them!
I can't craft you if you're still alive!
Oh...
Dino, die!
Okay, I will go to you.
Crawl to them!
I will go to you.
Dino, I can't craft because you're still alive!
Dino, crawl to them!
Make them kill you!
You can't!
I almost died!
Wait, wait!
I will craft right now!
Dino, crawl to them right now!
Okay!
Wait, wait!
I'm going to die soon!
I'm dead!
Okay!
Dino, why did you die faster?
Oh, sorry!
I'm sorry!
Okay, I'm resting.
Okay.
We lay here and we go...
Why did no one kill you?
They don't kill me!
No one wanted to kill you!
You were alive!
You were alive for too long.
Oh my god!
Maybe I'm too useless.
They feel so bad.
They feel so sorry for you.
They didn't want to kill you.
They're like, no.
It's too sad.
Yeah...
Okay.
Wow.
Oh my god, there's actually...
I'm so fast.
Alright, let's go check epicenter then.
They're still fighting!
You want to look at it?
I know.
Do you want it?
We can look at it.
We don't have to fight.
It's over.
Oh yeah, it's over.
I want to take high ground though just in case.
Can we loot here?
Yeah, you guys can loot here.
I'm just making sure our high ground is safe.
It's looted but okay.
Yeah, see if there's extra loot.
Did we scan epi yet?
No, right?
No.
Yeah, we took a scan epi.
Epi, okay.
Yeah, scan.
Okay, okay.
Scan epi.
I have some valley here.
I like new crafting.
It's so fast.
Yeah, but you can only craft once.
Yeah.
You're fighting on the high ground here.
Okay.
I'm trying to make sure our high ground is safe.
Oh, I see people here.
Okay.
Oh.
I'll take out a zone soon.
Okay, I'm at the high ground.
Red armor?
I want to make sure they don't come to us.
These guys.
Oh, they're on team there.
Oh no!
One team, one guy, one guy, guys!
One guy, one guy!
Team right here where I'm looking at.
Okay.
This guy.
This team is coming to us?
This team, this team, this team, this team.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, there's a team coming to us here.
I'm coming to you guys.
I can't give you...
Wait, oh shit!
Okay.
There's a team here.
You're okay?
I'm dead, I'm dead.
The team came to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's fine.
Leave me, leave me, leave me.
You guys can craft me.
Wait, I'll die to zone.
I'll die to zone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm dying to zone and you can craft me.
Okay, I will revive you here.
Yeah.
I didn't realize how fast they were to me.
I heard they were that close.
That's how you die, Ditto.
That's...
Why?
That's how you die.
Wait, wait.
Where's the...
Where's the place?
Where's the rest?
Yeah.
Where is it?
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, shit!
Oh, he's trying to get...
Okay, okay, it's fine.
Just rest.
Yeah, Utho can cover.
Okay, okay.
Come on, come on.
Come on.
Maybe...
I think he was trying to rest.
I think he wanted to rest.
That's really it.
Alright, nice.
I have zero...
We gotta go to zone.
Let's go.
We're so poor.
No ammo.
No ammo?
Heavy.
I don't have it.
Oh, below us.
Below us, right here.
Is this a team?
I think this is a team.
Yeah, there's one team.
Nice.
I need a healer.
No team, no team, no team.
Careful.
I'm looking.
Come to me, Utho.
Come to me, come to me, come to me.
Back up, back up, back up.
I think we need to go a different way.
We might have to go drop down.
Whoa, whoa, be careful.
Nice to ask that.
Oh, I saw him.
Nice, nice, nice.
I saw him.
We can be right below them.
Yeah.
We stay up here.
They can't do anything.
Oh, look over there.
They can't do anything about us here.
Let's say drop down.
I don't think they'll drop down.
They're not.
Yeah, they won't want to.
Okay, they missed.
Do you have shields or no?
Okay.
I have a health shield.
Don't worry, we're safe.
We're so safe.
We're so healthy.
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
We're so healthy.
Do you have shield cells, Uto?
I have a health shield.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I will give you guy Q.
Okay.
Oh my god, no, no.
We can't, we can't.
This team is going to drop down on us.
Unless...
Okay.
Oh my god, leave us alone.
We're so poor.
Yeah.
Okay, wait.
Do you think we can run?
Okay, who?
Okay, get ready.
Three, two, one, go.
We run.
Come here, come here, come here.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Careful, be careful here.
In front of me, in front of me.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Let's go, guys, go.
Go first, go first.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Don't look back, don't look back.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're safe, we're safe.
What the fuck?
Close the door on us.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Come here, come here, come here.
One, okay, okay, okay.
It's me.
Okay, okay, okay.
Other team, other team to my right.
Keep it on the side.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Last team over here.
Nice one, nice one.
Here, here, here.
Okay, I'm gonna try to charge my ult.
Oh, shit.
Okay, okay, I'm trying to get my ult.
I'm burning one.
He's on...
It's a rev.
Careful, Zeno.
Oh no.
I'm coming over.
Oh no!
No!
Top two!
We did it!
Next game.
Next game champion.
Nice, nice.
We did our best.
We were so poor.
But we did it.
Why are we always so poor?
We were so poor.
Okay, now...
Now champion.
I'm Revenant.
I'm playing...
I'm playing Mystery Heroes right now.
Okay, T2 and...
Now champion.
Yeah.
Ahhhh.
This is it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Oh my gosh.
There's no way.
We can't...
We can't fuck up.
We can't.
We got top three.
We got top two.
Now it's champion.
Champion.
Go!
Alright, let me see.
Total Shadow Palace cooldown reset.
Reduce tactical cooldown.
Which one's good?
Ahhhh.
We were so poor but we still get...
Um, second.
We were so poor.
I don't know how we did that.
I don't know how we were able to...
We died like twice.
Attack for more.
Okay.
Total Shadow Palace charge time.
Cooldown reset on knock.
Um, two teams.
Okay.
Oh no, I should get...
Agile Assassin and Grim Reaper.
Yeah, only one.
Alright, we got this.
Um, I will...
I will land here.
I'm landing here.
Oh no, two teams.
Two teams.
Oh no, three teams.
Three teams.
What the heck?
Wait, three teams?
That's not good.
Wait.
Did I just hear someone near me?
Yeah, someone near you.
Yeah, someone's near me.
For sure.
I have like this.
Yeah, someone's near me.
Be careful, Doki.
Yeah.
I'm coming over.
Please don't get shot.
I'm okay.
Are we gonna fight them?
No?
Do it.
Let's go.
We're in silver.
Go?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're in silver.
Okay, okay, okay.
I don't know where they are though.
Inside this building?
Inside this one, I think.
Yeah.
Careful, Ditto.
You're by yourself.
Woohoohoohoo!
Nice.
I got to heal myself.
Oh, very low.
Revenant very low.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
I wanna know where...
Where, where, where is Revenant?
Splash?
Nice.
Nice one!
Maybe that's... Oh, that's Rev?
Nice!
Oh, you paid Rev!
Yeah, see?
We just need Rev.
Rev champion.
Okay, I need...
Silence.
I need like 150.
I need 150 for...
Wait, is there more?
Oh, already got all of this.
Oh, I should have used my med kit.
I didn't want waste.
Double charger.
Up, up, up, up.
Do you have more syringes or no?
In a station?
Do you have syringes or no?
Um, I have two.
Okay, I have like... I'm good.
It's fine.
I have zero.
I didn't... I thought I had more.
Oh, I have all of them!
Nice!
Okay.
Do you need one?
I can get you one.
Okay.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
I have ult.
Nice.
Okay.
They're all high ground though.
The guy right here.
I can upgrade my push.
What do you think?
It's mine!
Whoa, so careful, careful.
Be careful, be careful.
Can you Q her?
Are they pushing or no?
No, no, no.
They're not.
They're not pushing.
I feel like we can chill.
Do we have enough meds?
I don't have...
I don't feel... I don't know if we should fight this.
We don't have a lot of meds.
We can back up.
Yeah.
Let's just back up.
And loot more.
Yeah.
I don't think we have enough heals for this.
Wait, wait, wait.
Another team here.
Another team.
We have to go.
Go left, go left, go left.
Another team all night.
That's why I won't go here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
That's a wingman.
Oh my god, that's a wingman.
No!
We don't have the heals for this.
We're too poor.
Not looted?
Wait, no.
Looted, looted, looted.
Oh, he's looted.
Maybe they're scraps.
Maybe that's the team.
There's stuff here.
Oh, here.
Enemy, enemy!
Enemy, enemy, enemy.
Okay, okay.
Where should we go?
We could go back.
I don't have a lot of heals.
Me too.
Let's go, let's go.
Yeah.
I don't want to fight.
Okay, okay.
My heals are so bad.
Me too.
I only have two silenies.
Baby.
I have zero survivors.
I have no syringes.
I'm just a little...
Baby!
Hello, I cried out.
Oh my god, the way you call me is so cute.
Creepy!
What?
I'm just a...
Baby!
What the fuck?
Where is the syringes?
I can't get one.
No.
No!
I'm crazy.
I already jumped.
I jumped already.
Where the fuck are the syringes?
This is looted.
This is looted!
Okay.
Oh no, it's half looted.
Nice.
I swear to god.
There's people fighting above me?
Like here?
Oh yeah, yeah.
One team above you.
Careful, careful.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe we can...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shoot them back.
Oh shit.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Shh.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
I think they know, they know.
Oh, they...
Yeah, they do.
They do.
They knew, they knew.
I can't point it.
I'm going back up.
Kill me, kill me, kill me.
Back, back, back.
Oh, back?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
We don't have, we don't have...
No!
Hello, I'm back.
I need 13 more!
Oh my god, we're so poor again.
Why are we always...
No money!
Where's our money?
Please donate.
A lot of silencers.
Can you guys pick that up for me?
I'm too lazy.
Can someone donate us some money to...
So we can not be poor.
Can I have some silencers?
Oh, nice.
Donate your materials to us.
Okay, I'm going to go grab...
The evil.
Oh yeah, I'm so close to evil.
Maybe we can go to the selfie cam.
How about selfie cam?
Let's go there.
Where the f**k is...
Yeah, I'm like 13 from...
13.
I want to go up too.
We're team poverty.
We're so poor.
I'll grab the evil harvester.
Okay.
Oh no, there's one team here.
Alright, there's a team here?
Yeah, they just take the save.
Leave!
We want to loot!
Hey!
I have like short range.
I f**ked that up.
Oh my god.
There's nothing here.
There's loot!
That's not alert.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, he went all the way there.
Is he rezzing?
I think he's rezzing.
Oh, you're okay?
Yeah, yeah, he's rezzing.
We throw this.
They have loot!
Go!
Okay!
We're going to be less poor here.
I'm going on the back.
I'm flanking.
Where are they?
Careful.
I'm going to tunnel.
Any help?
Crypto?
I'm coming.
Crypto cracked!
Down!
Two cracked!
Careful!
Just there.
I'm healing.
Wait, what the f**k?
Why is that so low?
Rob him!
Take his money!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We thirsted one.
Team behind!
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
I have nothing.
We still have nothing.
We couldn't rob the guy.
I'm going to rob the guy.
Okay.
Leave us alone!
Please!
We just watched them move!
Oh my god!
They're pushed!
They're going to push!
The seam?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm looking... I'm looking behind them.
I'm looking right!
Yeah, I'm looking left.
I'm going to...
I'm covering left right now.
Are they going to push us?
No, they're not.
They're not.
I think so?
One's close.
Okay.
I hear him.
If they push, I would...
He's super close.
Do you have Q?
Q?
Q, Q, Q.
I caged one!
Got him!
Push, push, push, push!
Last one!
Flash, flash, flash!
Oh my god!
Thanks for the loot!
Thank you, thank you!
Nice, nice!
Thanks for the loot!
Oh my god, we're not poor!
Yum, yum, yum!
Oh my god!
Finally!
We have money!
That was so sad.
That was like the saddest game.
Okay.
I heard people...
Oh wait, nice, more loot here.
I can't up-gain my perk!
What is this?
I wanna check if there's people here.
I think they're gone.
We can stay here.
I don't wanna go inside.
Oh, me too.
Yeah, me too.
Let's look for people.
Okay.
I'm gonna craft a bat.
Anyone need that?
No, I don't think so.
It's in this box.
Kraber!
Who wants the Kraber?
Oh!
That's pretty far.
No, it's like right next to us.
Actually, yeah, never mind.
It is.
It's like right here.
Okay.
But, I don't know, it might be too dangerous because it's in the middle.
I mean, I can try and get it.
I'll try and get it.
I'll drop my... I'll drop my power for it.
Okay.
I will look a lot if there's...
Make sure I don't die.
Yeah.
Okay, who wants the Kraber?
I don't.
I don't use Kraber.
Utyl, do you want Kraber or no?
No.
No, no, no.
No?
Why?
I love my nemesis.
Over here?
They're far, they're far, they're far, they're far.
I'm fine.
I'm covering you.
Yeah, it's fine.
I cracked him.
There's a bow check right here.
I'm good, I'm good.
Two blue, two blue, two blue there.
I'm okay.
I will keep this place.
This place is pretty good.
Okay.
I will make sure if there's no one come from our right side.
Yeah.
They're here.
No one, no one, no one.
Our right side, no one.
There's people fighting...
Yeah, there's people fighting.
I'm looking.
I'm reading.
Maybe I can quell.
Yeah, I think so too.
There's a team right here.
Oh, there's a guy right here in front of me.
Okay.
He's right here.
Oh, I missed.
Just try and roll down.
Come on, he's like sliding.
Oh my god, there's someone come, someone come here.
Help me, help me.
Oh, fuck.
There's a...
I'm gonna get back, I'm gonna go back.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Okay, I don't think...
Guys, I should not have Kraber.
I shouldn't have Kraber.
Guys...
Hey!
Someone take this Kraber off me.
One guy, one guy.
There's a guy here.
Please, take it.
You use this.
No, no, no.
No Kraber for me.
Wait, where's the Pathfinder?
Oh.
Yeah, there was...
Oh shit, look at that Collat.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
We have to take this hop.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Where the fuck is that Pathfinder though?
Inside.
One knock, one knock.
One knock?
Okay.
I don't know, we should...
I finished him.
I'm so scared of the Pathfinder behind me.
Okay, nice.
Uhh...
Let's see, I have five bullets left.
I hit like three of those bullets.
Uhh...
Let's see, is there a Pathfinder behind me?
Is there a Pathfinder behind me?
Oh, careful.
Oh, Pathfinder, Pathfinder here.
Oh wait, he's on me.
Behind the rock, behind the rock.
Dead.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Only two teams left.
One team duo and full party.
Full team there.
Yeah.
On my right.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna come to you guys.
Oh!
Is it down?
Woah.
Oh my god, I stuck in the door.
I'm gonna heal.
Let me just...
I couldn't swap my guns.
Where are they again?
Uhh, up top.
High ground.
One's high ground.
High ground, okay.
Okay, I'm here.
140?
He's not gonna peek now.
No!
My door!
Maybe we can play...
here.
I just don't wanna be in the middle.
Okay, okay.
As long as we're not in the middle, we're fine.
We can go later.
Is that one rat?
Is that a rat?
No, it's four teams.
Oh, okay, okay.
Four teams and one team duo.
Okay.
Oh, they knocked that one!
Knocked one.
One to 12, Karthus!
Oh, nice one!
Nice one!
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
I want...
I can't.
I'm thirsty.
Knocked one!
I'm healing.
Only two.
Careful, careful.
Inside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
On me?
Give me a Q.
Burning one?
I'll kick him.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, no!
Come here, come here.
Just cover.
Come here, just come here.
Come to me.
High ground, high ground.
Come to me, come to me.
I don't think we should...
I don't think we should fight this now.
We should wait.
No, no, only...
There are two teams.
Yeah, but...
They're resing.
Oh, they're resing too.
You can rest me here.
I'm trying to cover.
I'm covering.
He's looking at me.
Oh, no.
Keep crawling.
Keep crawling to me.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
You're fighting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why I'm chilling.
Just crawl, just crawl.
I'm resing.
You heal.
I res.
Do you have Q?
Oh, you used Q.
Okay.
I'm batting.
I'm batting too.
Careful, Uto.
Drop, drop, drop.
Leave, leave behind me.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Oh, fuck.
I'll give you Q.
Q, Q, Q, Q.
Oh, no.
I don't have Q.
I'm healing.
Full heal, full heal, full heal.
They're resing too.
I can revive.
Just res.
You res.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
Give me Q.
Okay, okay, okay.
Where are they?
Above, above, above.
I'm fine.
I'm batting.
Full heal.
It's 2-2-2.
2-2-3.
Okay, 2-2-3.
Yeah, yeah, careful.
I have one Kraber shot.
Oh, my god.
This fucking team.
Not the bat.
I have no bat.
Of course.
Can I just try it again?
Okay, it's 3-3-2.
3-3-2.
I'm waiting.
Just wait.
Chill.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
I hope I got that.
I got that.
When do you have Q?
Me.
Yeah, now.
Now.
Okay.
Give me.
Give me Q.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I give you.
Flash, flash, flash.
Nice.
Armor swap.
You have to.
Can I?
Oh, no.
I'm dead here.
I don't have Q.
I couldn't.
I had only one gun left.
We're so close.
I had one gun.
There was like three times.
Yeah.
That's you.
Oh, my god.
I had another gun.
If I had another gun.
It was so close.
We almost got champion.
Oh, my god.
I should help.
I should help finish them.
No.
They had hammerpoint.
We were so close.
Where is he finding hammerpoint?
Okay.
I'm gonna be right back.
I'm gonna use bathroom.
Okay.
Champion.
That was close.
I'm back.
Okay.
Same team.
I bet you we can get champion if I find hammerpoint.
Okay.
I just need hammerpoint.
We were so close.
Only hammerpoint.
Yeah.
Okay.
That was so close.
We were so close.
I can't believe.
I can't believe they rez'd three times.
They didn't push them.
We didn't have DGI there too.
Do you have a team?
Yeah, they have a team.
One party.
They're friend of me.
Oh my god.
I got car and ulti.
I got car and Spitfire.
I got left side.
I'll look at my side.
Just to be sure.
They're coming over.
I see them.
Careful.
Oh, zero.
Two.
Two of them.
I'm heading over.
So close.
They're inside.
Yeah, all three.
I'm coming over.
They're all three on you.
All three on you.
One crack.
I'm coming over.
Oh no.
So close.
Careful.
Oh my god.
He missed me so hard.
Careful.
I'm trying to help you.
Flush.
One down.
Nice.
They're pushing.
Flush.
Oh no.
They're low.
Two low.
I'm healing.
Healing.
Where?
No armor.
Where did they go?
That was bad for me.
Oh.
He had the Q.
Oh nice.
Oh.
They push you guys so fast.
Yeah.
They push you.
That's so unlucky.
Oh.
If I push...
I didn't...
I didn't think they would push so fast.
I was too slow behind.
I was still running.
Nice job.
Nice try.
Okay.
That doesn't count.
That game doesn't count.
We don't have hammer point.
Yeah.
We lost.
Because no hammer point.
Every time we lose.
No hammer point.
Okay.
That's the only reason why we lose.
Hammer point win.
Yeah.
Fine hammer point equals win.
Exactly.
Okay.
We can do it.
I believe in us.
Yeah.
Look.
Everyone in gold right now.
They are like master players.
Masters plus.
Okay?
No.
But we are paid.
We are paid.
Yeah.
Exactly.
But like...
You know.
We are...
Our ping is like 500 ping.
Remember?
Oh.
Yeah.
I forgot.
And they are fighting hammer points.
How?
Okay.
What the fuck?
They are all gold.
Alright.
You know what?
Where do we go?
We go here.
Okay.
Hot drop.
I believe in us.
Wow.
Two.
Two?
Two teams?
Two.
Two teams.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Maybe they like us.
Oh.
Two.
The... The...
What is that?
Is that the melee?
Is it?
If it's not, it's third party.
Oh.
Okay.
Good.
Good for us.
Got a gun.
I got a gun.
Alright.
Are we gonna go?
I'm going over.
Yeah.
One down.
I'm going over.
Go.
I'm going.
What the fuck?
It's okay.
You are strong.
I'm going.
Go.
I believe.
Come here.
Oh wait.
No wait.
Okay.
I want a scan.
Yeah.
Scan.
They are resing?
I can't reach.
Something...
I think they res.
They res.
I think... Wait.
Wait.
Just wait.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
I knocked one.
Yup.
Nice.
On my fourth.
Oh.
Wait.
Where are they?
Two.
Two here.
Oh.
Come here.
Here.
Photo.
Two here.
Oh no.
I'm coming here.
No.
Two.
Crack.
Horizon crack.
No.
Wait.
Where is the other team?
Horizon crack.
No.
Wait.
Where is the other team?
They ran away.
They ran away?
Really?
What?
Why?
Oh my god.
I thought.
Where is the other team?
Where?
Yeah.
I'm watching the runway.
Where did the other team go?
What?
How dare they?
I won't report them.
I can't believe it.
What's the point of third partying if we can't third party?
What?
They...
They were there but...
Okay.
They...
I bet they were walling.
I bet.
They knew.
I bet they were walling.
Where did they die?
Oh.
I lied into two people.
Okay.
Anyway.
The only reason why we died is because we don't have hammerpoint.
Oh.
Anyway.
The only reason why we died is because we don't have hammerpoint.
Oh.
Yes.
Yeah.
Two.
I can't believe it.
So mean.
They're so mean.
They won't let us third party.
So mean.
I know.
They're so mean.
Yeah.
I'm gonna report them.
Whoever they are.
Can't believe it.
Those fucks.
Okay.
This time I will be more careful.
I believe in us.
Yeah.
Calm down.
I went the wrong way.
Oh.
No one calmed down.
I heard you say, I heard you say, I heard you say, I didn't calms down.
I didn't calms down.
I just hear down.
Is there anyone here on us?
Oh.
One team.
No.
Oh.
Liar.
No.
I saw.
I saw someone above us.
Whoa.
The server is.
Yeah.
Watch your backpack.
Like that.
A car.
I feel so sad.
The R9 is so garbage.
R9 is so bad now.
Not that good.
Why is the R9 so bad?
I want them to buff R9 back.
Me too.
I feel so fucking weak.
You can't escape.
You're so weak.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna cough.
I will keep it.
I forgot you.
You're like...
Oh.
I want you to buff R9 back.
Thank you.
Cool.
I got a... I got a key.
Let me know if you guys find a backpack.
I have no backpacks.
Backpack?
Two.
Two backpack there.
Yeah.
I'm getting it.
Pallor.
Okay.
I got a 30-30 and a...
Pallor.
Okay.
I got a 30-30 and a...
I have a 30-30 and a R9.
I have...
Backpack.
Why is it so hard to find?
Have you guys ever seen one?
Yeah.
Did you guys ever...
Have you guys seen one at all?
Two times.
Two times?
Yeah.
Two times.
Like in your life?
Yeah.
In my life.
What the fuck?
What is the spawn rate of that stupid attachment?
Maybe you have to go to the...
I thought...
Hudson?
If you go to Hudson...
Oh, maybe.
I have a key.
Wait, wait.
No.
Maybe in the vault.
I have a vault key.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Yes.
In your whole life.
I mean, in your season.
In your season.
I mean...
I only see it two times.
I think I saw it like one time in the new season.
Alright.
Come on.
Hammer point.
Just a gold bag.
Same as Turbo Shot.
Hammer.
Hammer point.
I took everything.
Who wants to take that?
Who's rezzing?
Do you need this?
Okay.
I will.
I think you should have it.
I think Conduit should have it.
The Q is better.
Okay.
Ditto.
Yeah.
Nice.
There's people fighting in Fragment.
In Fragment?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
It got all gold.
All gold.
Go.
Alright.
I don't know where they...
Okay.
Let's see first.
Yeah.
They were here.
There's a... Oh!
I see them.
Wait.
Where?
Here?
Oh.
Wait.
Are they fighting?
No?
No.
I think they finished.
Yeah.
And the meter?
Do we want to fight or no?
Um...
Uto.
Do we fight or no?
Yes fight or no fight?
Okay.
Let's fight.
No.
Alright.
Let's go.
Go.
Careful.
Be careful.
I don't know where they are.
Me too.
I lost them.
Oh.
To your right.
Right.
Enemy.
Yeah.
I will take...
What?
Blue.
Blue?
Here?
Two blue.
Here.
Here?
In front of me?
In front of you?
This corner.
Horizon 2.
Scan.
I'm going over.
Wow.
Hit.
Cracked him.
Can you kill me?
Nice.
I got one.
Got one.
I'm covering.
I'm packing out.
Okay.
Can you...
I'm gonna go.
Are they sim or no?
They are running.
You're gonna run.
Over there.
Almost k.
Line.
You are so annoying.
I'm batting.
Okay.
I'm going.
I'm pushing.
Okay.
Do you have scan?
They are like super split.
Yeah.
I'm pushing up.
I'm pushing.
They are scanning me.
I'm going up.
Hey.
I'm going up too.
On me?
Wait, behind me?
Oh, there.
I'm gonna bat real fast.
Oh, here?
Yeah, they're super split.
Push this guy!
He's split!
That's Rave!
They're so cute.
Do you have Q?
Let's go, let's go.
No, I don't have Q.
Oh, okay.
You don't have Q.
I'm backing out then.
Wait, I'm getting shot from two angles!
Two teams!
Two teams, two teams, two teams.
Okay.
Are we down?
Are we going down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Back out, back out, back out.
Two teams, two teams.
We're going back out.
I'm backing out.
I'm, I'm, I'm back.
I'm going back.
Goodbye!
We can destruct her again!
Okay, okay, okay.
We can remake her!
Just run!
Now, now, like two teams.
Yeah, one has a wingman and I don't fuck with her.
I don't fuck with that.
Okay, okay.
The wingman is scary.
We can make, we can, we can craft her here.
Okay, I'm gonna shin my gun.
I'll craft her.
Okay.
Oh shit.
Ooh.
Okay.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm good.
Alright, you can res her.
Okay, I'm gonna go lay her here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
I'm gonna lay her here.
Thank you.
Oh, I feel like this.
We can build her stronger.
Alright, we're fine.
See, nothing to worry about.
Yeah.
Like she never dies.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
We're so far from zone.
I don't have heals.
I wanna... I'm gonna go to zone.
I'm going here.
Okay.
Wait, there's people here.
There's people here.
Okay.
You good?
No.
I'm pretty far from you.
Yeah, I'm just trying to see if I can...
Okay.
I'm going to you.
Oh, nice, nice.
Nice aim.
No.
No, it was not.
Okay.
It was very bad.
Are you trying to finish them?
Yeah, I finished this guy.
There's another.
It was... it was very sad.
I can't... I can't finish them.
It's okay.
We need to go to zone.
I don't want to fight you.
They're going to revive that guy.
Okay.
They're gonna... Well, it's two people.
It's two... No, no, no.
Wait, wait.
They're fighting.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna try to revive.
Yeah, we can... We're there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can...
We're there.
You want to go third?
Yeah.
You might have heals.
Okay.
I will... I will... I will use my ult.
I got what?
Nice.
Is it okay?
Have heals?
I don't know if...
Die.
One... one die.
One die.
Okay, there's still another.
No more?
Are they all dead?
Oh, they all... They all dead to my ult.
Nice.
Okay.
Here, here.
Nice.
Hammer point!
Woah!
Oh my god!
Hammer point!
We did it!
Holy shit!
Wait!
Holy fuck.
Wait, can I get rid of it?
No, I can't.
Whoops.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait, where's the hammer point?
Who has it?
Where is it?
Hammer point, where?
Here, here.
Hammer point, okay.
Nice, nice.
Okay, I'm gonna medkit.
Oh my god, so, so, so...
Oh, wait.
Do I get this off?
So...
Yes.
Okay, I'm okay.
Yeah, this don't hurt like hell.
Yeah, so hurt.
Oh my god.
This is it, this is it!
I forgot to grab Digi, but this is it!
I just, I'm just missing Digi.
I'm fine!
Let's go, only one.
One minute.
One minute left.
Okay, it's fine, we can go from here.
I have three medkits.
Okay, okay, I only have one, but...
Yeah, I'm fine.
I can give you...
Oh, yeah, I can give you one later.
No.
No medkit.
No more?
Okay, I can give you though.
Thank you, thank you.
One team, one team, they are fighting.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
Wait, what?
I forgot.
Did you forget to heal?
Okay, okay, okay.
I forgot to heal because I was yelling at your name.
Be careful, be careful.
Okay, okay, I have to heal, I have to heal too.
I have to go to zone.
Okay, I'm good.
Oh my god, the first time I've ever seen a hammerpoint.
Nice.
The second time.
Finally got hammerpoint.
I finally did it, everybody.
We don't have much time.
We have to go, we have to go.
Maybe we can go from left side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, but I give you syringe.
Do you have syringes for her or no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can give her one, I'll give her one.
Okay, I only have two.
I will give her one.
We have two, two, one then.
Okay, there's someone with a Kraber.
I have nine, but I have only one syringe.
Someone has a Kraber.
Careful.
My right side?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what?
Got him, got him, got him.
Nice.
I don't know where his teammate is though.
Oh, the Kraber, Kraber, Kraber.
Careful, careful, careful.
Careful.
I want...
The time to raise, the time to raise.
Scan, scan, scan.
Scan, scan, no, no, no, scan.
Okay, okay.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I got him.
I'm bad, I'm bad, I'm bad, I'm bad.
Nice, nice, nice.
Just wait.
Team, team here, team here, team here.
Wait, wait, wait, come back, come back.
Okay, I will come back.
Come here, team here.
I'm covering.
I'm gonna cover here.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Team, guy here.
Careful.
Okay, I'm good.
I will go on top, I will go on top.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just, I'll cross.
There's a guy right here, he's running back.
Okay, I will go top.
Muru, Muru, Ama.
Guy right, team here.
Wow.
Oh my god, this team is so...
Okay, I will go cross.
Okay.
I will go cross.
I just wanna make sure this...
Yeah, this guy is blue.
He's over here.
Oh my god, that's another...
He is so low.
I think our spot is pretty good.
Yeah, it is.
We'll just stay here.
I'm gonna loot.
Is there like a 4x, like a 2x4?
Oh my god, I have 11 battery.
Oh nice.
There's shield cells too for us.
I have too many batteries.
I don't need it.
Me too.
Fuck you.
That's right, you don't get rez.
Is there a guy here or no?
Yeah.
Okay.
Behind the box.
I don't have angle.
Behind here too.
I'm safe right now.
I should be fine.
Okay.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
I'm gonna make sure no one is behind us.
No rats.
No rats?
Maybe.
I will check here.
I'm checking right now.
No rats.
Only cheap teams left.
There's a team here and then a team to our left.
And another team there.
One running, running, running.
72?
Oh, so long.
Got him, got him, got him.
Nice, nice.
But we can push.
I can push.
I can, I can, I can.
Can you cover me?
Okay.
I thirsted him.
Okay, over there.
Yeah, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Okay.
We're fine.
That team is one person.
That team is a solo.
Team over here.
Look, look, look, look.
They might come to us.
Look at this, look at this.
Cracked him.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
Oh my god.
I'm in.
Oh, nice.
He has Kraber.
Okay, okay.
I'll give you kill.
It's fine.
I'm good.
I'm just stringing.
Okay.
I don't know where the second team is.
The second team.
No.
Oh, wait.
Solo, solo three.
Solo three.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is a solo.
Fuck off.
You're solo.
Get out of here.
No, this is all cheap.
I think there's four teams.
No, no.
I killed...
Fuck off.
No, I killed one here.
I killed one.
He's a solo.
I'm coming over to you.
They're gonna come to us.
We have to focus that team first.
Okay, I need...
Yeah.
Come here.
We're high ground though.
We have high ground.
So we're fine.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
And we also have hammer point.
I feel like he has... Yeah, we have hammer point.
If they come close to us, we have hammer point.
Flash, flash, flash, flash.
This guy.
Ah.
Nice.
One down.
I focused this team.
This...
Yeah, yeah.
This team.
He's a solo.
Don't kill this solo.
Don't kill this guy.
He's a solo.
We want the solo to help us.
One guy solo.
Yeah, he didn't thirst him, right?
Oh, I don't have...
Oh...
I don't have angle.
I don't have angle to kill them.
I'm batting.
Don't kill the solo below.
We want him to help us.
Okay.
Yeah, see?
He's helping us.
We want him to help us kill this team.
Okay.
There's our secure member.
Yeah, he is our...
He is our teammate.
He is our fourth player.
Ooh.
Kill him.
They want to kill the rat, but we won't let them.
Look at how many heavy ammo do you have.
I have 178 here.
I can get 58.
Okay.
Thank you.
Move back in.
Nice.
They have to run.
They have to run to us.
Skyeong?
Nice.
Shoot.
Shoot the people on this.
I'm fine.
Safe.
Safe on me.
Right here.
Safe on me too.
Bloodhound.
Crack.
1-1-1.
Oh, he's so low.
Bloodhound here.
Bloodhound was 1.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Can you help us?
We will make it.
Crack.
Flash.
Down.
Nice one.
One cracked.
Nice.
Nice one.
I will ult them.
Alright.
2-2.
It's actually 2 down there.
It's 2.
What the fuck?
I thought it was 3.
I thought it was 1 but it's 2.
That's fine.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
It's the solo.
Bro.
Stop.
Can
we go there?
Can we go there?
Can we kill Jango?
Crack.
What the fuck, Crack?
Nice.
Oh my god.
I knew it.
Hammerpoint win.
I only used Hammerpoint once.
That's fine.
Nice.
I only used it like one time but that's okay.
We still won.
Yes.
That's good.
I told you.
That's all we need.
We just needed Hammerpoint.
Every time we get Hammerpoint, it's a champion.
Yes.
I find you, Hammerpoint.
Yeah.
It's like lucky.
We get lucky when we have it.
Yeah.
You're right.
We also have a good position too.
I knew it.
It's all we need.
Oh.
So good.
Oh my god.
We weren't poor too.
No.
We're not poor.
Yeah.
I love it when we're not poor.
Me too.
That's us!
Nice!
Auto, where?
Countdown.
Countdown, yeah.
Okay.
Let me see.
I think no one...
Wait.
One team?
Okay.
I'm not sure.
I'll look.
I'm gonna loot inside.
Only one.
One team?
No.
No team.
No team?
Okay.
I'm looting inside.
There are like four teams in Skyhook.
Alright.
We search Skyhook.
Okay.
You're a better gun.
Skyhook.
Oh.
Well.
Take that.
Are we gonna find Hemlock or...
Oh wait.
I found Hemlock.
Nevermind.
Nice.
Oh.
Yeah?
I'll take that.
It is...
I don't have that.
Oh.
I found one too.
Nevermind.
Yeah.
Alright.
I'll go.
Here's... if anyone wants that.
It might be...
We did it.
Yeah.
Oh.
Pryler.
Nice.
Oh.
Okay.
You know what.
30 30 was so nice to me.
I'm gonna take it again.
Okay.
Uto.
Show me.
Go.
4K damage.
Good luck!
Pro!
Yeah, pro, remember.
You can do it!
You are pro, right?
Are you a liar?
No, no, no.
Wait, are we going to skyhook?
4K.
I believe.
I have a key.
Oh, a key?
Oh, okay.
Let's go key.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Gotcha, gotcha.
Okay, let's go.
Alright, let's go.
I will go take the armor.
Alright.
Oh yeah, the harvester?
Yeah.
Hammer point.
Whoa!
Hammer point?
No.
No?
No!
No hammer point?
No.
Wait, fight in front.
I'm going to go.
Okay, enemy.
Yeah, enemy.
I heard a grenade.
Okay, I will make our...
I will make our...
Oh, I see.
I will make our army.
I'm pretty far.
Be careful.
Oh,
big house.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we wait.
We wait, we wait.
Wait for Ditto.
Okay.
And rez too.
Maybe they come to me.
What?
No, no, no.
You're so far.
What do you mean?
They're here.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
I'm going to fight in front of them.
Maybe only one.
Oh, it's two rez.
No, no, no.
It's two to do.
Two rez, two rez.
I'm going, I'm going.
Tell me if you need Q.
Climb out.
Okay, I'm climbing out.
I don't need Q yet.
No Q, no Q.
Two.
Let me know when you crack.
When you crack, I'll call.
Not crack, not crack yet.
Okay.
I can... Okay, I'm waiting.
Waiting too.
Wait, they're white armor.
Kill me, kill me, kill me.
Oh my god.
Crack one.
Nice.
I don't know where teammates are.
Oh.
Crack.
On me.
Knocked one.
Nice.
They were white armor too.
Haha, babies.
Baby.
Where was he?
Where's one of them?
Wait, someone, someone.
Oh wait, I hear someone.
Jump pad, yeah.
Tower, tower.
Oh yeah.
Okay, where?
Are they gonna come?
No, no, no, no.
They're here.
Okay, they're far, far, far, far, far.
Very far.
Okay, okay, okay.
Crack.
I'm good.
I'm gonna heal.
Whoa.
They have man man game.
Chill.
Where are the other boxes?
I don't know.
I'm flying, I'm flying.
You ping me some of the boxes?
Wait, they might push.
Okay.
Yeah, they're coming closer.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, they're here, they're here, they're here.
They're here.
Careful.
They're inside, they're inside.
Yeah, they're inside.
Uh, third floor?
Yeah, yeah, let's go to third floor.
Let's get out, let's get out.
Yeah, I'm not.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm down, I'm down.
I might be dead here.
Oh, I cracked him?
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Run, Ditto, run!
You can craft!
Don't be a hero!
No hero time, just leave!
Leave!
No, Ditto!
I'm leaving, I'm leaving!
Don't be a hero, just run!
Oh, they're controller.
By the way, they're controller, just leave.
All three of them are controller, just leave.
Okay.
Go as far as you can, so they can't aim assist you!
Seven feet!
Cause it's out of the six feet range.
Okay.
Make sure you're seven feet away.
Let me sh...
Oh, you should heal though.
You're so...
Oh, svej, svej, come, svej, come.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Make sure you're seven feet away from the controller players.
Okay, seven feet is...
Yeah, so you don't get me and get killed.
I wish I was a roller.
Why didn't we learn controller?
Okay.
Nice.
I think I should...
No, your res is here.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't know if they're gonna come to us.
Okay, they do.
We run.
Wait, we're not being cowards.
It's strategy.
Oh, I see them!
I see them!
Run, run, run!
Oh, they're out.
Okay, I run.
Run, PS1.
Okay.
Just run, just run.
Yeah.
They saw me, they saw me, they saw me.
They saw me.
Just run.
If one of us lives, that's okay.
Only one has to live.
What the heck?
What the fuck?
It's okay.
Just one of us has to live.
That's all we need.
Okay.
See you, see you later.
See you later, everybody.
See you later.
We'll meet again soon.
Okay, I'm safe right now.
Are they chasing?
Nice, nice, nice.
They're chasing me, they're chasing me!
No, why me?
What?
Okay, this is a controlling friend squad.
Wait, you attacked him?
Wait, who did that?
You!
Who killed you?
What is it here?
Who?
Who killed you guys?
Oh my god.
This chasing shit's all hard.
You know what was worse?
They were controller friend players.
Not only were they friend, they were controller friend.
Controller friend, I see.
They were less out of life.
That changes everything.
Guys, it wasn't stream snipers.
They're just good at the game.
We would know if it's stream sniper.
We would know.
They saw a rez and they saw me.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh my god.
They are so thirsty.
They want more kills.
They want to get to friend again.
Oh, I see.
Is that a friend team?
Yeah, that was a friend team.
Oh, we are friend 2.
Yeah, but they're controller friend.
That's different.
That's better than the pro player.
That's better than pro.
Oh my god.
Let's see.
Like, they pushed us.
They pushed us so fast.
Holy shit.
Yeah, they pushed us so fast.
When I got deleted, I was like, oh god.
I was just like, they just...
I didn't want to live in this game.
Oh, 72 players?
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
This is two lobbies.
Yes.
It's still noon.
Everyone is sleeping.
No, wake up.
You don't sleep when you're grinding rank.
Alright.
Yesterday, I watched ChenVertian's team.
Yeah.
He had been still playing.
He was still streaming for 46 hours.
Holy shit.
Yeah, number one Pred.
Yeah.
It's not like he's gonna keep it.
Because he has scrims.
He has pro league.
Yeah, so like, what's the point?
I guess he wants to be the first team.
Like the first player.
But he's not gonna keep Pred.
Yeah, it's because he has to do ARGS.
Yeah, he has to do ARGS.
There's no way he's gonna...
Normally, people who do rank 1 Pred has like... is like content creator.
Because they don't have time.
Oh yeah.
Yes.
They don't have time for rank.
Uto, when are you gonna do Pred?
Come to Pred.
Pred?
Yeah.
Yeah, Uto.
Pred?
Get Pred.
Yeah, you.
Get Pred?
No, no, no.
Why not?
Why?
Fake news.
Get Pred.
You can get Pred.
No, I'm not gonna go play.
So easy.
No, we don't have to.
We already got it.
Yeah, but Uto.
Pred.
When?
Prato?
Yeah.
Today is today.
Today?
You told me there's people here.
Not today.
I give you cue.
Please, why didn't you tell me there's a team?
Oh, I didn't see.
One team?
Really?
Yeah.
Look at my HP.
Two of them.
Am I lying?
I see him.
He's over here.
Solo.
Pass fighter.
Okay.
Got that one.
No, no, no.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm pushing.
Don't let them res.
Do you have cue?
Crack?
Low, low.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
One down.
Nice.
Last one.
That's fucking right.
Nice one.
Yeah.
So, Uto, when pre-ed?
Uto.
Today.
So good.
Yeah.
Today?
How many hours?
46 hours?
24.
26.
24 hours?
Yes.
You stream for 24 hours?
Dido and I can end stream and you do 24 hours.
What the...
Go.
That's too much.
No, no.
She will do 24 hours.
We sleep.
No, no, no.
No, no.
You didn't tell that you're gonna play with us.
Yeah, you didn't tell us.
We sleep.
No.
No, no, no.
You can't sleep.
Oh, she can't sleep?
I feel like Dido now will get pre-ed before she gets pre-ed.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Uto's basement is clear.
Okay, so Dido doesn't sleep.
I sleep.
No, I sleep.
Wait, why are you asleep?
No, no, no.
Why?
No, sleep.
Sleep.
Wait, this is looted.
Every time.
It's looted?
Yeah, yeah.
On me.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay.
I'm going.
Whoa.
On me.
Yeah.
I can give you a scan.
I'm good.
I'll need it.
They're like over here.
They're here.
Oh, wait.
He's seen me.
Whoa.
I'm batting.
I have one.
I'm healing.
Full heal first.
Yeah, you can full heal.
Scan.
Oh, close, close, close, close, close, close.
Oh, my god.
Do you have Q?
Yeah.
I know.
No, I don't.
They push you.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Give me Q if you can.
Q, Q, Q, Q.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I'm good.
Inside, inside.
I'm so fucked here.
I got, I got knocked one.
One, one, one.
Oh, 2v2.
2v2.
One down, one down.
Last guy here.
Here, last guy here.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm good.
Where?
Here, here.
So close.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Hello.
Hello, Azzy.
Oh, you're so low.
Console!
Bitch.
Yeah, Paolo, Paolo's controller is cracked.
Bitch, I should boot up my Switch.
I should play Apex on my Switch right now.
Oh, my constantly misses.
I still have Laura in my PC.
Oh, my god.
Ah.
Bitch!
Bitch.
Yeah.
Bish.
Nice.
Ah.
What?
Okay.
I will full heal first before peek.
Oh.
Alright, here we go.
Where are we going?
Countdown?
Okay.
One team.
One team?
Yep.
Alright, here we go.
They're gonna land there, I think.
Oh, they're gonna land here.
Oh, you're landing there?
I'm gonna land here then.
Okay.
Oh, my.
Oh, PSS.
Wee-oh.
Okay.
Got my Prowler.
Woo!
Wait, is there a team?
Yeah, there's a team.
Okay, okay.
I'm coming over here.
I have Hemlock.
Wait, where are they?
Where are they?
Are you sure?
I'm going to Ditto.
Inside the building?
Yeah, you're by yourself Ditto.
You're by yourself.
Okay.
I'm still good.
They have Caustic.
Okay, I'm here.
Caustic low, Caustic high.
I'm here.
Low, low, low, low.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm pushing.
Help Wutou.
Nice.
Where the... Oh, nice!
Wait, where's the last?
Oh, last on me?
Flash?
Nice.
Easy.
More prowler?
Oh, I...
What the f***?
Run, run, run!
Goodbye everybody.
Why did you...
No sound!
Oh my god.
No sound.
Yeah, they just showed up.
Yeah.
Only...
The only audio that I can hear is a gunshot.
No sound.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
We stay easy, We stay easy, and they kill us.
And we just die so fast.
Oh my god.
There's a curse word.
Oh...
Nice, nice, nice.
Go next.
Oh my god.
Nice try, nice try.
That's crazy.
Ah...
Okay,
okay.
Let's win.
We end on champion.
Okay...
Yeah, we end on champion.
Yeah, and then Uto can keep playing and get Pred.
No!
I want to sleep!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I crashed.
No!
No, I go sleep.
My crash!
We end on champion!
But, no, okay.
Ditto and I end on champion.
Uto keeps playing until Pred.
Uto ends on Pred.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yes.
No, no, no.
Yes, yes.
I believe.
We believe, right?
We believe in Pred Uto.
Yeah, Uto, show us your Pred.
Yeah.
One team, one team!
Okay.
Wait, but what about me?
Yeah, bye, yeah, bye.
You're good?
I'm good.
I'm here.
Okay, nice.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need gun.
I go get gun.
Nice, nice.
Two guys on left side.
Wah, wah, wah, wah.
Alright, I'm good.
One guy there.
Alright.
I'm good now.
Yeah, let's do that.
Okay.
I'm ready.
I'm gonna open this then.
I'm ready for you guys.
I don't know if they are leaving.
Are they?
Are they still in?
On me, on me, on me, on me!
On me.
Cracked?
I have to back out.
I cracked one though.
I need help.
Okay.
I'm trying to cover you.
Are they coming to me?
They're still here.
They're still on bridge.
They come to me.
Yeah, they're coming to Ditto.
We have to help.
Careful.
I'm here.
I'm on bridge.
Wait, where's the third?
There's no third.
Oh, it's duo?
They're getting inside.
Okay, I'm inside.
Careful.
Help.
Help Ditto.
Okay.
Only two?
Oh, sorry.
Three, three, three.
I'm dead here.
Nice one.
Oh, I cracked them though.
Last one, last one.
Yeah.
No more, no more, no more, no more, no more.
No more shields.
No, it's conduit.
It's conduit.
Sorry.
It was three.
Oh, we're so close.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's okay.
We end on champion.
This is it.
Okay.
This time.
Now I know what to play.
Oh, champion.
Nice champion.
I think we got two champions today.
No, it was one.
Oh, one.
One.
It was one.
Oh, no.
We got one.
I thought we got two.
No, we got...
We got one.
Okay, one.
One.
Look, we're nerfing ourselves.
We're nerfing ourselves.
That's all.
Guys.
It's cause we were purposely playing bad.
We're...
We play on 500 speed.
Yeah.
This is all on purpose.
Wow.
A lot of...
Master here.
Master.
Oh my god, I got...
I got lost.
Lost.
There you go.
Come on, we can do this.
We can win a... not second game.
Just lobby broken.
We can do it.
I got so many lost.
Oh no, that's not good.
One team.
I'm okay.
Two teams?
One, one, one.
One, one, one, one, one.
One over there.
There's a...
On top.
Fuck, okay.
There's a guy behind me.
I'm going to you, I'm going to you.
Oh, what?
Yeah, yeah.
Behind me.
Oh my god!
Wow!
I got stuck.
I'm fine, I'm fine, I'm okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
I'm worried to help you now.
Pack one.
Alright, here.
It is two, it is two teams.
Careful.
Okay, two teams, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
This lobby is so laggy.
Maybe we can go...
Train?
Yeah.
Yeah, okay, we can go.
Let's go, let's go.
Oh, it's landslide.
It's not train yard.
It's the same thing.
There is two, because there's a team behind us, I'm pretty sure.
Okay, okay.
And we are going to get sandwiched.
We should leave.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want to get sandwiched at all.
We also have bad loot anyway.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's not hammer point, it's a score PSO.
This is, this is why we've been losing.
We haven't been finding hammer points.
There you go.
Our luck has not been good to us.
Let's go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Oh, there's loot here.
What?
That, oh, that, careful, careful.
No, that was me.
Okay.
That sounds like enemies.
That was me.
Like enemies, that sounds really like enemies.
Revenant.
Oh yeah, scan?
If you can.
Okay.
Yeah.
The guy.
Okay, okay.
I will open the box.
I'm gonna see if there's anyone near us.
Oh.
I won't, I won't craft yet.
I will keep it for...
Let's see.
We'll try to see if we can kill.
Actually, I feel like we're gonna get thirded.
I don't know who to fight actually.
Our loot is so bad.
Yeah, and the...
I think we should keep loading first.
Yeah.
I mean we can go here and see if they start fighting it in Fragment.
Okay.
Oh okay, yeah yeah.
That's nice.
Yeah, I'm gonna go over then.
I'm gonna start going to Fragment.
Woah, Energy Mag.
I'm gonna get up here.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Yeah.
That always scares me.
I feel like I'm being shot.
I know, I know.
Uh... grab the hemlock.
If you found any skull, please tell me.
Alright.
I think it's two.
Two eggs or two.
Skull piercer?
Skull piercer.
I think it was like a long time ago.
Oh no, I got it.
I got a skull.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Are they still fighting?
I have no idea, but I'm looting right now.
Okay.
Uh... I'll check.
I think I'm good.
I think I'm good with my loot.
I'm gonna go check and I'm gonna grab a harvester.
Oh, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, in front of me.
Oh, woah woah woah.
New team.
New team here too.
Wait for the new team.
Wait wait wait.
Yeah yeah yeah.
But...
Okay, okay, okay.
Only one.
This guy.
There's a guy right here.
Oh no, no, no.
One team here.
One team, one team, yeah.
Over there.
Yeah, there's three teams.
I'm ready, I'm ready.
They're still...
They stay there.
Yeah yeah, and there's a team here too.
Under the bridge.
They might fight each other.
Yeah, they're pushing, they're pushing.
They're pushing, they're pushing.
Knocked one.
Nice!
Knocked one, nice one.
On me, on me.
Here.
Almost caked.
Crack crack crack crack.
Over our house.
This is three...
This is a full team behind me.
Very weak, very low.
Okay.
Teammates here, teammates, teammates.
Oh, I don't have ammo.
Fuck.
No more ammo.
I don't go light.
I think we have to back out.
Oh my god.
There's still three teams, there's still three teams.
Okay, okay.
I'll go back.
Yeah, yeah, come to me, come to me, come to me.
Okay, okay.
I didn't get a kill.
Full kill.
Do you guys have heavy?
Wow.
No.
I have heavy, I have heavy.
Yeah, yeah, can I have some?
You have some.
I'll give you one stack.
Yeah, thank you.
I'll give you one stack of G.
Thank you.
Thank you for the one stack of three.
They all left.
I think they rez too.
I think we, we can finish them.
That Horizon.
Where's that Horizon?
I don't, I think, I think they rez her.
Wait, my, my, my, it doesn't work.
My Uri, my Uri, my Uri.
Wait, what?
I don't know, maybe it's bug.
I'm trying to see if we can find them.
Wait, they're fighting again.
Here.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
I think that's them.
Okay.
Careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They got knocked, I think.
That jump head here.
I'm going over.
Ooh.
Grab this.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Far, far though, far, far.
Okay.
Can I shoot?
Oh no, I'm not, I'm not gonna shoot that.
They're far, they're far, they're far, they're far.
Okay.
Tell me if you need my Q.
Wait, oh, that's you.
You're so far.
Oh.
Are they lying?
No, they are chasing.
Far?
What the fuck?
They're chasing another team.
They're still running.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Enemy, enemy.
Almost hit.
Oh, I couldn't get him.
I'm gonna climb up.
Oh, fuck.
How did I climb up?
Okay.
I'm climbing up.
It's okay.
I'm gonna push this one.
Careful, careful.
Careful, you're by yourself, you're by yourself, Ditto.
Okay.
Almost keg.
On the purple.
One team, one team here, one team here.
Cracked him, cracked him.
I'm batting.
Just remember you're by yourself.
Almost keg, another one.
Okay.
Oh my god.
These guys are annoying.
I'm looking for you.
Oh, he's so low.
He's fresh.
Yeah, he's far from me.
Oh, nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, that's mad, mad game.
Where did you, where did you kill him?
On my ping.
Okay.
I'm ulting.
Thank you for the Q.
I give you Q.
I don't see them.
On me.
Okay, okay, okay.
He's low, he's low.
He's low.
Oh, I might be dead.
Oh my god, he's so low.
I'm dead.
I'm going back.
I'm backing up, backing up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't, I can't.
Over here.
I think they rez.
Okay.
Yeah, they're laning so fast.
Yeah, because there's mad Maggie.
Why?
So low, so low, so low.
Yeah, I have to heal.
Nice, nice.
I have to heal.
I can't go.
They might rez again.
I will ult.
No, no, no.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
Maybe they ran away.
I think they ran.
Yeah.
All right, we rob him.
Nice one.
Good food.
Delicious.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should go.
Delicious.
They are still fighting.
In the tunnel.
They are?
Yeah.
Oh, here?
Oh, okay.
In the tunnel.
There's a team here.
I'm going to go to the one that threw the crack.
Solo, he's solo.
He's fresh, he's fresh.
He don't have armor.
Oh, he's here.
Come over here.
Oh, hey, package.
Come on, where are you?
Go, go.
I will leave it to you.
Let's go.
Come on, where are you?
He keeps running.
Faster, faster, faster.
Wait, he got the fucking wingman too?
Bitch.
Let's go, let's go.
He's solo.
Oh, my God.
I'm so mad.
He lived.
Oh.
He fell.
He fucking lives.
Enemy, enemy, enemy.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
There are two.
I'm here.
Crash.
Oh, here's Uto.
Uto Crash.
I'm going to cover.
Oh, my God.
I'm going to try to cover.
He's getting shot.
They're getting shot.
Okay.
Try to cover.
Me too, me too.
I'm trying to cover too.
Hey, I'm covering.
I'm covering.
Oh, I have to back up.
I can't help.
I can't one.
I have to back out.
I have to back out fully.
I will go too.
I can't help her.
Because there is another team shooting at me.
Another team there.
Only two.
They shot us.
We have to go high ground.
I have no bat.
I have bats.
Actually no.
That's my one bat.
Wait there is people here.
There is people here.
Here.
Wait what did I hear?
What?
Wait they are rising.
They are rising.
Below us.
Yeah.
Right here.
I will heal first.
I am going to make sure no team runs into us.
They have a point.
Yeah but...
I am going to check for...
There is two.
There is two?
Okay.
I am going to...
Climbing up?
Yup.
I am climbing up.
Where?
Where are they?
I don't know.
I ulted.
Go on.
God damn it.
My ult.
Oh my god.
They are so far.
I ulted.
I have a point.
Okay.
Oh my god.
My hammer point.
They are so fast.
Why?
Are you running?
Oh no.
I need heavy ammo.
I don't have one.
Okay.
Let's loot.
Oh my god.
We can't kill one.
I make like...
1000 damage but I have no kill.
Oh my god.
They keep lying.
I know.
Fucking bitch.
Okay.
In front of me.
Two teams.
Okay.
Be careful.
I'm gonna get some loot.
Yeah.
What?
Oh nice one.
Nice one.
There's another team here in front of me.
Oh my god.
I was trying to loot this guy.
That's fucking right.
You thought you could run.
Oh my god.
He's so rich.
Do you need heavy?
Yes.
A lot.
Yeah.
He's rich.
Actually I'm gonna grab the prowler.
Oh nice.
Nice kill.
Yeah.
Careful.
They have to come to us.
They're not in zone.
They're right below us.
I'm gonna shoot below.
Okay.
Right here.
I'm gonna...
I'm right there.
Behind this rock.
Oh.
Wait.
His teammates are right here.
Is that the same team?
Wait.
That's another team.
Oh shit.
Woooo.
Yeah.
Careful.
Nice.
I got one.
Careful.
They're not in zone.
I need to heal.
I only have small meds.
Okay.
Only small meds.
Crack one.
Oh.
I'm pushing.
You're gonna push?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Santa point.
I'm going.
I'm coming.
Down.
Nice.
Nice job.
Okay.
That's my ult.
Do you have Q?
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
I have Q.
Yeah.
Give me Q.
Crack.
No.
I need a bat.
I'm good.
Do you thirst him?
I'm gonna thirst him.
Where's the hammer point?
Where is it?
Oh.
They are so poor.
They have no health.
Nothing.
They didn't have it.
What the point?
Where was it?
Oh.
We have to go.
Do you have redeploy or no?
I have.
I have hit here.
And then me here.
What was in that?
I don't remember.
Alright.
We have to go.
Wait.
We can actually go here.
Do you wanna go tunnels?
Yeah.
Okay.
We can go tunnels.
Tunnels.
Yeah.
Tunnel.
Alright.
We should be.
One team near.
Yeah.
Let's just stay in tunnel.
I can't believe the guy we didn't kill was the one with the hammer point.
I'm so sad.
I'm so f**king sad.
Of course.
I will look left.
Okay.
There is no one.
Maybe we can get...
Can we get above?
On top.
We can go here.
They are fighting each other.
Apparently.
But I have my Q.
I'm gonna scout.
One.
One fresh there.
And I wanna make sure we don't get flanked.
Okay.
They have 2.
Can you scan back here?
Yeah.
I knew it.
I knew there was people there.
Nice.
I think there was a fight there or something.
Okay, one, two, and another team.
I'm not sure where are they.
Someone here, I think.
I don't have angle.
No angle.
Okay, me too.
You guys watch here, I will watch our back.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need a heal.
I want to make sure the team to my left doesn't push us.
Yeah, you make sure the team...
Yeah, solo here.
The guy has red armor.
Cracked.
Nice.
We get the solo.
I heal the solo here.
Do you guys have light ammo?
No, no.
Does the solo have light?
Focus here, focus this guy.
By himself.
Behind this rock.
I'm going back.
Yeah, someone...
Okay, this is really really close.
I'm going to just...
Here, this guy.
Oh, I don't have a lot of ammo left.
I can't give you heavy ammo if you want.
This is not zone.
Okay.
Do you want heavy ammo?
Oh, okay.
Alright, never mind.
I can't shoot anymore.
I'm watching, I'm watching, I'm watching.
We are still in zone, but this team is...
I only have short range.
Wait, they are resing.
What?
Hmm?
Who resed?
Maybe that team.
Oh, I guess so.
Oh, this team.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
This team is in zone.
I don't want this team to push us.
I'm just gonna wait.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna wait.
I don't...
I only have close range.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
What are you using right now?
Carbine, Prowler.
I don't have Light, so I'll just... I have Prowler.
Careful, careful!
Here, I'll cover, I'll cover.
Oh, they're right below me.
They're Q'd below us.
Okay.
Be careful, they are...
He's...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're right below me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right here.
I'm looking at climb up.
I can't get any anger.
I'm making sure they don't climb up.
This team on our left, this team has to come to us.
Or this team has to rotate first.
Careful, Ditto, they might rush you.
Okay, okay, okay.
They might try and rush you.
I think we should be like a bit closer.
Let's go.
Yeah.
One o'clock.
Nice.
Come here, Gabri!
Here!
Ooh!
Here.
Careful, Ditto.
Yeah, don't let them push up.
Yeah, I'll throw that away.
Okay.
Just make force...
I won't force them to go this way.
There's the one guy here.
Yeah, I'm looking at the portal.
I'm looking at the portal so they don't push.
You all up, guys?
One...
One keg.
Can I zoom?
Can I?
Yeah.
Can you scan?
Yes, scan.
I got the belt, I got the belt.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna go.
Oh, no, this is bad.
There's so many people on us.
Oh, my God!
There's a guy team above us!
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Careful, careful.
Play slow, play slow.
Oh, what the fuck?
No!
Oh, my God.
Wait, they all pushed us and he hit us.
Holy shit.
So close.
Yeah.
That was so close.
I thought they would push each other, but they put...
Oh, my God.
That was so close.
I didn't push.
They did.
They knocked like one, and then they like chilled.
They knocked one and chilled.
Yeah, they knocked one and was like, never mind.
Nice try.
C'mon, we need that champion.
Oh, my God.
Who do you...
Eh, it just sucked that I had zero ammo on my other gun.
No ammo.
Okay, let's see.
I wanna try...
I'm gonna try Bangalore.
Okay.
It's Bangalore time.
Here we go.
Okay.
We can get...
We can get champion.
We can do it.
Champion number two!
Champion number two, okay?
Yeah, no sleep until champion.
And then...
Uto, no sleep until Pred.
Okay.
Oh, we sleep.
We go sleep.
Yeah, we go sleep.
We wake up and then...
No!
And then Uto's still playing and then we help her and then we get champion and then we go sleep again.
And then Uto...
And then Uto keeps going.
I'm tired.
Good luck, Uto.
I believe.
Good luck.
No.
Doki, no sleep.
Pred, no sleep.
No, no.
I'm so sleepy.
Oh, me too.
Oh.
I'm so sleepy.
I can't aim.
I can't aim anymore.
But Uto, you're not sleepy.
You're not sleepy.
I'm sleepy.
No, no, no.
Wait, what time?
No!
Oh my gosh!
I'm sleepy.
Wait, what time is it in Japan?
What time?
What time, Uto?
Sleepy.
You're sleepy?
Oh my gosh.
What?
When you wake up...
Don't let me die.
I'm coming back.
What?
I crashed.
Yes.
Don't let me die.
There's no one there.
Don't worry.
You're not gonna die.
No team, no team.
Don't let me die.
I'll be very angry.
You won't like it when I'm angry.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Okay.
I loo...
Uah...
dwgw.
Alright, let's see.
Got my ultra natr.
Do you want an alter natr?
No.
I Build it fall into natr.
I wanted...
Let me know when I find disruptor.
Beautiful.
Wait, there's a Prowler.
You want Prowler?
I'm going to run double heavy.
Double heavy?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm crazy.
I know that.
Okay, we're all crazy.
We play Apex.
We're crazy.
Yes, you are.
You're the craziest.
Uto, is Ditto crazy?
I'm not crazy.
Crazy.
Yeah, is Ditto crazy?
A little crazy.
No, no, no.
Uto is crazy.
Yes, crazy.
So crazy.
Number one crazy.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Fuck you, Uto.
Fuck you.
There's a blue backpack here.
I'm not crazy.
Okay.
Oh, that's mine.
That's mine.
Oh shit.
I'm being alert.
I tried to jump.
I was like...
I almost jumped off.
Alright.
I got my double...
Double heavy.
Nice double heavy.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh, another guy back here.
Hammer point.
Nice.
I need... I need...
I found RE.
Win.
It's win.
It's win time.
Okay.
I found... I found RE and fucking hammer.
This is it.
Nice.
I have six.
I have six battery.
Anyone want it?
Yeah.
I have... What the fuck?
I have one.
Okay.
Alright.
Give me...
I'm poor.
Okay.
I... Okay.
I... Here.
Two.
Beat me.
Beat me, mama.
Mama?
Beat me.
Uto mama.
Uto is... Uto is grandma.
Baby.
Oh my god.
Grandma.
So old.
Obacha.
Grandma.
Baby mama grandma.
Oh, fighting sky.
Okay.
Sky hook.
Yeah.
Finally here.
Another one.
I'm good.
Yoink.
Let's go.
From back.
Yeah.
They don't know.
They don't watch.
They don't watch their back.
Yeah.
They're so stupid.
Okay.
I'm gonna go from... Yeah.
You guys go from top.
I'll go from bottom.
Yeah.
You guys go from top.
I'll go from bottom.
Because you know when it's done, the door is open.
You two go top.
Also I wanna loot this too.
They don't know.
I'm gonna wait until it finishes.
Are you shooting?
Are you shooting them?
Yeah.
Another gun here.
I cracked one.
Wait.
Where are they?
I cracked two.
Where?
Only one guy left?
Yeah, the last guy ran.
Woah!
Okay.
You good?
Give me a sec!
I'm fighting my demons!
I'm fighting my demons just now.
You good?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Oh look, all eyes.
I got only one kill.
Yeah, I got... yeah, the guy ran.
Scan?
Maybe they're leaving.
What?
She scanned?
Oh my... oh, there's a scan here.
No, I got two kills.
I'm gonna...
Enemy!
Here!
Where?
Oh yeah, there.
I'm coming over here.
Oh, no!
Careful!
Oh, wait a sec.
Careful.
I got the heal.
Okay.
I'm trying...
Oh, I don't see.
They run, I think.
Yeah, they run.
They run.
They're okay.
I want...
I got...
Heal!
We can...
We can redeploy.
Wanna redeploy?
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna just redeploy.
I know there was a scan.
There might be a team here, I think.
Okay.
Are you here first?
Goodbye.
See you later.
Sayonara.
Goodbye.
Are you good there?
Yeah.
Safe, safe.
Okay, okay.
Let's save.
I want heal.
Wait, do I have med kit?
Oh!
I have the full heal for you.
Okay.
Do you need med kit?
I don't have it.
Here.
I'm using signage.
I have an extra med kit for you.
Okay.
There's a team here.
Enemy.
I don't know where they are, but I saw like a package come down.
Oh, we have to go to the zone.
Okay.
I'm gonna run to the zone.
Careful, careful.
Okay, okay.
Maybe we can scan.
Scan the enemy first.
Yeah, yeah.
And locate.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Let's scan.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
I have so many heavy ammo.
Oh no, I'm not gonna cross.
I'm not gonna cross.
Oh shit.
Hey, there's two teams here.
I think we should go to zone.
We should go to zone.
Go to zone?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Okay.
We might get here and here.
Yeah.
Nice.
I'm gonna head... get to high ground.
Okay.
One team down.
Yeah, there's two teams here.
Maybe we can play here?
Yeah, we play here.
Yeah.
Okay, okay.
Enemy here.
Okay.
One team.
Enemy.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, what?
How did they get here?
Don't look at me.
I'm climbing.
He didn't see me.
In front of me.
Flash.
Crack.
He's so low.
Oh shit!
He looked at me!
Crack.
Okay.
I can't.
I can't do anything.
You have to heal.
I have to heal.
Careful.
There might be a team behind us.
Be careful.
Yeah.
Another squad shooting.
I'm gonna look behind us.
Yeah.
Team behind us.
Okay.
I'm gonna cover.
I'm trying to cover.
Okay.
I'm trying to make sure they don't run to us.
I want them to go low ground.
Okay.
Be careful.
We can lose.
Oh my god!
There's so many teams!
I'm making sure this team...
We can get inside first if we... I think we don't have...
Careful.
Here.
I kept one.
Okay.
Two.
Two there.
Above us.
Okay.
I'm looking at the one...
Oh shit!
Goodbye!
I'm okay.
I walked backwards.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
Nothing bad has happened to me.
I'm gonna try to smoke you.
Oh, we can't help you actually.
No, you're way too far.
Oh, that's another team!
That's so unlucky.
You're way too far from us.
Yes.
Yeah, I fell down and... I'm trying to get to you, but how?
Oh, they have A1-8.
Careful.
Yeah, I'm batting.
Wait, okay.
Do you have redeploy?
What the?
You have redeploy, right?
You are?
Okay!
Yeah, I want backup.
I want to back up.
They're gonna walk up.
There's three.
Yeah, that's them.
Oh, behind us!
Oh!
That's not good for us.
They might push.
Yeah, they're pushing.
They're pushing.
Back up, back up.
Yeah, I might die.
Uto, you run.
Just run.
Just one.
I'll then run.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
No!
Oh, no!
I should've...
I'm the enemy!
No!
Two teams behind, and I need to get out of here.
Three!
Three team?
Three?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Goodbye, see you later.
Sayonara.
Goodbye,
see you later.
Goodbye, see you later.
Goodbye,
see you later.
I got jinxed so hard.
If they don't know they are cheating, I'm going to use the bathroom.
Cheating.
Such good game sense.
How did they know?
Oh...
I'm gonna eat hamburger today.
Oh, black mushroom.
It's truffle.
In English?
In English, it's truffle.
Mushroom.
That's right, truffle.
Wow.
Doki, do you like truffle?
Huh?
One party.
She's dead.
Doki dead.
Oh, wake up.
Doki, wake up.
I found hammer point.
If you want hammer point, tell me.
Tell me.
Wake up.
Oh, she's...
She's dead.
Dead.
Assault.
Japanese time.
Oh, no.
Where did she go?
She's dead.
She'll come back later.
I think she's dead.
I'm back, but I crashed.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I'm back.
Wait.
I have hammer point too.
Wait, there's enemy?
Enemy.
Here, R4D.
Okay, okay.
Protect me.
I'm important.
I'm protecting you.
Protect me.
One of us, okay?
I believe in all of you.
Oh, you guys can do it.
You're so good at the games.
Don't die.
I have no gun.
One K.
Okay, I'm coming back.
Okay.
I'm here.
Oh, my God, there's a god.
Where is it?
Where's the hammer?
Oh, my God, they are.
Yeah.
I'm coming up.
So close, so close.
They're on the side.
They're coming over.
I'm gonna try and grab a gun.
Alright, triple sniper, let's go.
Wait, what?
Wait, there's another...
Yeah, I'm getting shot by a different angle.
One guy, one guy so far.
Solo.
Oh, I'm going to...
Yeah, I'm going to Udo.
Nice, nice, where are you?
I'm here.
Nice!
Is there a safe?
Oh my god, please give me a different gun.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Above us, above us.
Above us.
Yeah, I'm going to... Okay, okay.
They're far.
They dropped down.
Not yet, not yet.
Oh, they scanned me?
I'm looking.
Scanned?
Crack one?
Nice.
Wait, on me?
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Oh, shit.
Second floor.
One, one, one, one.
Where is he?
Nice, he was one.
Yeah, nice.
Nice, nice.
I helped Ditto.
Nice!
Look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry.
Easy, easy.
Easy.
Oh my god.
I was not scared.
Wait, where's the helicopter?
Oh my god, nice.
Helicopter's here.
I saw it down here.
What?
Where did it go?
Oh, here, here, here.
Here, here, here, here.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is it.
This is it.
We win.
I'm healing up.
Okay.
We win.
Do you have a gun?
There's a disruptor here.
Yeah, I have a vault and a flatline.
Okay.
Here, on R.E., R.E.
45.
Let's see.
Okay.
Let me know you guys find a 30-30.
30-30 okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to loot the other side.
Okay.
I'm looking for a car or a parlor.
I need 30-30.
Parlor, oh there's a parlor there.
Oh, nice!
Boki present!
Oh!
There's a 3032!
Happy birthday!
Oh, I don't need it.
I found another one.
I'm returning your birthday present.
Yay!
Oh, I'm gonna head to zone.
I don't have enough meds.
I don't have meds.
Goodbye everybody.
No.
No prowler.
Nice, I found a DG2.
Here.
There's a lot of prowlers.
Okay.
Okay, we use prowler and iron 301.
Yeah, prowler 301 is alright.
I need...
A fucking scope.
2x or... 2, 3 or 2, 4.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the scope?
Hello?
I don't have prowler.
Yeah, it's empty.
Still trying to find...
Trying to find a scope.
My 3030 is naked.
So...
So cold.
Okay.
Fragment?
Fragment.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Nice one.
Okay, I'm gonna go to fragment.
Alright.
I go to fragment.
With my...
My 3030 is not naked anymore.
Oh, I need...
Oh, nice.
Yeah, I needed that.
Hmm...
I don't hear gunshots anymore.
Me too.
I feel like...
Do you guys need battery?
Nah, I have 5.
I have 5.
Okay.
Me too.
We're rich now.
We'll never be poor again!
Battery?
Yeah, you need battery?
Okay, I got it.
Thank you.
I will keep...
Where the f*** is this team?
I'm scared we're gonna run into a team.
Okay.
I'm so scared.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll keep hiding down.
Oh!
Do we run?
Do we leave her?
Okay, we leave her.
We leave.
Sorry.
Goodbye.
See ya.
See ya later.
Bye.
Here we go.
Skyhook?
Yeah, we can.
We can.
I'll meet you on the other side of Skyhook.
If one of us dies, the other can just craft this.
Okay.
I hope it's you so I can keep my hammerpoint.
Be you.
Who's gonna be the lucky one?
You.
Why would it be me?
I'll go craft, you go res.
Okay.
Seems like there's no one here.
I will go grab armor first.
Alright, got her.
Oh, we lucky!
We have good luck!
See?
It's Uto.
That's unlucky.
What if I got killed by the laser?
Unlucky.
She is the unlucky one.
Nice!
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Thank you.
I think we should go here.
Okay, I have to...
...cover Uto first.
She'll be fine.
Okay, yeah.
You don't need to cover her.
She'll be okay.
She is strong.
She's a pro.
Oh, you're right.
Hmm...
She has a power move.
Oh, you can scan this too.
You won't get shot at, Uto.
You're so lucky.
Okay, okay.
Uto, you can scan this.
Don't worry.
I'll stand in front.
Nice, nice, nice.
You're so lucky.
Oh, we're so lucky.
Yeah.
Is that you?
Okay, I was gonna be like, who is that?
Me!
Okay.
I'm gonna make sure no one... I'm looking this way.
I really like...
Alright, Uto.
Scan.
I'm okay.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I'm blocking you.
I'm blocking you.
Don't worry.
Oh, what the fuck?
Wait!
Go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go!
Uto, go kill him.
Uto, go kill.
We'll wait here.
Why not?
Yeah, we should.
I feel like everybody's gonna run here.
So we should go here.
That'll be fine.
Uto.
Can we go first?
Yeah, we should go now.
Okay, Uto.
Come, come.
Okay.
Okay, this place.
This place is free.
Yeah, it's so free.
Alright, you're gonna go high ground?
Okay.
Oh wait!
Yeah, why the fuck am I going low ground?
We can stay on high ground.
I'm a little silly right now.
Are we...
Are we gonna stay here or go inside the ring first?
I feel like... No, we can go stay up.
Because like no one's gonna contest us on our side.
I feel like.
Wait, who's...
Oh, there he is.
Where's the solo?
On me.
Wait, he's gonna rez.
He's solo.
No!
He got it off!
The stupid solo!
He actually got it off.
Okay.
I cracked him too.
He has to come to us.
Yeah, he does.
There's no cover here too.
There is actually, never mind.
Here.
He has one.
Two!
No, because we saw him as a solo, remember?
Wish I made Uto kill him.
Yeah!
I'm sorry.
I told you guys!
I didn't...
I knew it!
Oh, crack crack crack crack!
Can I horizon?
Behind the car.
Oh, so close.
They will get killed.
I don't think so.
No, they're safe here.
Okay, I will watch our back.
Yeah, you watch the other side.
I wanna make sure.
Yeah, we can just go here later.
I don't want this team to run on us.
Are you washed here?
I want them to leave us.
Okay.
Oh yeah, they're running.
Yeah, leave.
This is our territory.
Okay, I'm coming over.
How much is this hurt?
Let's go inside the lane.
This doesn't hurt too much.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Drop down.
Yay!
Wow!
I'm gonna make sure no team runs behind us.
Okay.
Oh no!
What?
How did he change?
Okay, goodbye.
Oh my god!
What the heck?
Okay.
My key is waiting for me.
See you later.
Oh fuck!
Goodbye!
Let's see.
I'm trying to figure out...
What does this mean?
Goodbye.
Sayonara.
He was camping.
Maybe you can grab my...
No.
There is no way.
That's not good.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody can grab that.
Fuck this!
You should have stayed with us.
No.
I'm gonna spawn a beacon.
We can't.
Crap!
I'll smoke.
I smoked.
Go Uto!
Go!
Don't worry.
I'll save you.
Careful.
I smoked.
Oh, you're resing here.
Okay.
I didn't realize you have respawn.
One team.
One team have duel.
Okay.
This is safe?
That's cool.
I didn't realize this was safe.
Yeah.
It's safe.
I'm gonna go kill that Bangalore.
I don't think you're gonna be killing anybody.
Wait.
What?
Inside.
Okay.
Ready?
Three, two...
Okay.
Nice!
I shot you.
I shot you instead.
Oh my god.
Don't shot me.
Don't shoot me.
You scared me.
Okay.
We're fine.
I need...
Look.
See?
You're not baby anymore.
I'm not baby.
But I need sail and shield.
And a lot of things.
We got everything we need.
We're okay.
Oh, Kraber.
Careful.
I'm back.
Oh, shit.
We're not in zone, guys.
We're not in zone.
I don't think we can get it in time.
But I'm gonna try.
We can.
But where do we go?
I don't know.
How about now?
Go here first.
We can.
I can't upgrade my perk.
This game.
This is scary.
I'm gonna go here.
Okay.
You guys go.
Nice smoke.
Guys, nice.
Okay.
Woooo.
Hey, I'm good.
I'm good.
Oh my god.
I don't like this zone.
Oh, this is a...
Careful, careful.
Careful, guys.
Am I right?
Woah.
I got one.
Careful.
Right side.
Look at right.
Okay.
I don't have nades.
I have no nades.
Why are you smoking me?
Kill them.
Oh, they died to me.
This is scary.
Oh my god.
Fuck off.
They got us gone.
Wow, wow, wow.
Fuck off.
Woooo.
Oh, KOTY.
Do you have ult?
No.
90.
90%.
Okay.
I got the ult to them.
But I don't know how to ult this.
I think ult right.
Ult right so they don't run to us.
Okay.
Oh, they ult us.
They ult us.
Fine.
Can you smoke them?
I smoked this area.
Okay.
I'll just go here.
I have ult.
I'm ulting left.
You ult right.
I'll ult left.
Say what?
Oh my god.
I should have ulted right.
I can't go.
My ult.
I can't run.
I'm not going on the left side.
Oh my god.
I'm fucked.
I'm dead.
You're not gonna die.
Really?
I feel dead.
Believe.
Okay.
I believe.
You're surviving.
To my right.
Careful.
I knocked one.
Let me know who you cracked.
What?
They're over here.
Careful.
Nice.
I'm gonna give you guys two.
Low.
Nice.
Armor swap.
Just armor swap.
Don't mind me.
Last two teams.
Last team.
I'm covering.
Oh my god.
Oh the Quaver.
I didn't believe.
That full head wingy.
Oh my.
What the fuck happened?
I got Quavered.
And then that wingman headshot.
I got shut down so hard.
Oh my god.
It's cause I didn't believe.
It's cause I didn't fucking believe.
Why did I stop believing?
You didn't believe so you died?
Yeah.
I didn't believe enough.
Oh my god.
Luminant.
I didn't believe hard enough.
My bad.
Nice try.
We did our best.
We tried our best.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We were so close to champion.
And then all of them was like No fuck you.
No fuck you.
I should have ulted right.
God damn it.
We were so close.
Yeah.
Champion.
This game.
This game will be champion.
I believe.
Oh my god.
We've been playing for four hours.
Really?
Yeah.
We've been playing for four hours.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Fuck those guys.
How dare they.
That's fucked up.
They won't let us sleep.
Yeah.
Right.
I wanna know why is this champion team.
Let's go land on them.
Yeah.
Where are you?
I'm gonna land on you and beat you up.
Come countdown.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
That's fucking right.
Come to downtown.
Release fist.
Yes.
Nice one.
Oh.
Oh fuck.
What happened?
Oh you fell?
I did a lot.
Nice.
Oh wow.
Let me see the power.
This is a champion comp.
Oh that's a champion comp.
Right there.
I hear skyhook.
Skyhook.
I'm heading over to Utho.
Okay.
This is it.
This is the run.
Do they push Utho?
No.
She's just existing.
I push.
You push?
Okay go.
Go.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Okay battery one bad.
Oh I'll take that.
Alright go.
Go save Utho.
Fighting.
Yeah we have to go fast before they finish.
Go faster.
Yeah.
Utho go faster.
Go faster Utho.
Oh he's so low.
Why didn't you kill him?
If he's so low he should have been dead.
Wait where's the other team?
I make him low.
Is he down?
Low?
I hit 10 on him.
Okay.
I want to team that.
Yeah they ran.
They don't fight each other.
Why?
What the f**k?
Come on.
Just gun and run.
Yeah.
I think they're there.
Yeah they did.
They were so scared.
Oh wait.
Left side?
Here.
Yeah.
He's solo.
Teammate.
Teammate here.
Teammate low.
I knocked him.
Knocked him.
Go go go.
Nice one.
I can give you kill.
Can I?
Finish him.
Oh they ran.
They ran.
Okay.
On the rooftop.
One more point.
Have a point.
Okay give me a sec.
I'm gonna...
Oh you're Youtube too?
Hello Youtube.
Hello Youtube!
Woops.
That scared me.
Be careful of all of us.
Oh wait.
What?
Yeah I saw him.
Can I?
Yeah yeah yeah I just saw him.
Okay, okay, okay.
I feel like we have to...
What are they?
Fighting each other, fighting each other.
We can...
We don't have to worry too much.
Flush?
On me, on me, on me!
Thank you.
I'm with you, I'm with you.
Oh no.
Slow, slow, slow, slow, slow, slow, slow.
Here, here, here, here, here.
I got him.
Nice, nice.
Help, help, help.
Behind you, behind you.
Crack.
Kill yourself first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait,
wait, wait.
Another team.
Yeah, yeah.
Another team, another team.
Armor swap, armor swap, armor swap.
Yeah, armor swap.
I'm healing.
Someone look at him.
Someone look at the door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna heal.
I can't go.
What is going on?
I'm trying to get ammo.
First floor?
I'm on first floor?
Oh no.
Wait, where's his teammate?
Maybe run away, I think.
Oh.
Nice.
I don't have medikits.
I only have syringes.
Yeah, here's med.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
I will torch this one.
Hmm, gonna run.
He's here.
Let's see.
I'm running...
Carbine, crowd... oh, vault.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
They don't have...
They don't have a lot of stuff.
I can get energy.
Like 24.
I mean heavy, heavy.
Oh, heavy.
Yeah, no heavy.
They don't have heavy.
Let's go.
Let's go from left side.
Yeah, I'm good.
Oh.
Yeah.
We have to heal.
Wow.
Nice.
We're so healthy.
No, my hammer point!
I don't know where the hammer point was.
I can't remember.
Uta found it.
Yeah, and then I didn't pick it up.
We're not getting champion.
No.
We can.
I'm lazy.
I'll see you guys later.
No.
I don't wanna run anymore.
They're fighting there.
Careful, left side.
Oh, they won't see me.
Wait, wait.
Alright, if I die, you're welcome.
Okay.
If I die, we're lazy.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
I don't have ult.
I'll give it to you.
What?
She doesn't have...
Help me!
Oh, no more meds?
Okay.
Thank you.
We should go...
Just go here.
We have to run before...
Because we don't have meds.
Okay.
I only have signage.
No battery.
I'm just running.
I only have three syringes left.
Make sure I have only two.
Someone died to ring.
We should go inside the lane.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm trying.
Someone's...
Ignore.
Don't look at them.
Just run.
We don't have meds.
They also saw us.
Yeah, but they're not shooting.
So they're pretending they didn't see us.
That means they don't have loot.
Yeah, so we leave.
We don't have syringes.
Okay.
I have three syringes.
Uto has zero.
But she's not going to live.
We fight with...
There's people here.
Run.
Go tunnel.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Alright, here we go.
Careful, careful.
That might be camping.
I need syringes.
Where are the syringes?
My syringes.
Nice.
No!
I'm not going to take it.
I know.
I know you need it.
Oh, he got my side.
There's another syringe here.
Yeah, I'm good.
I have my syringes.
Uto needs it.
There's a team in front here.
Thank you.
Team in front.
Okay.
On me.
Okay, I will give you...
Oh, f**k.
Oh my god.
I'm going to give you...
Here too.
Uto.
On me.
Okay.
Free kill.
Oh, free kill.
Nice.
Free kill.
There's another party.
Another party.
So many parties.
They're here.
Have you go back to other back?
Yeah.
It's fine.
That's the one team.
Yeah.
They're like all the way there.
We can...
We can go forward.
Like...
Maybe go here?
Wait.
I hear...
Peacekeeper.
This is... This is zone.
This is zone.
Okay.
Let's...
Yeah.
Let's go there.
It's fine.
I love free kills.
Yeah.
They rez this guy and then left him to die.
He has no gun.
Wait.
He was actually AFK.
Okay.
This man has zero guns.
How poor.
That poor man.
Here's syringes.
Okay.
Nobody here.
Again?
Oh my gosh.
This is too far for me.
Check if... I'm gonna check if anyone...
Stop.
Okay.
We have... We gotta go.
We have to go.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's very risky.
There's an...
It's very risky but we could go through a tunnel.
Enemy.
Umm.
That one?
She's on the beach.
Yeah.
But there's a team here too.
Enemy.
Oh.
I see it here too.
This is scary.
Where do we go?
I don't have redeploy.
They're crossing?
Oh.
Now they know.
Wait.
I have ult.
Okay.
I'll ult here.
I'm gonna ult here.
They come up.
Yeah.
But they have to run.
They have to run then.
And then we can walk up here.
Yeah, we can walk up.
It's time to walk up.
Okay, nice.
Alright, let's see if there's anyone above us.
There's people here.
I...
I don't think there's anyone above us.
Yeah, we're fine.
But there's team here though.
Oh, I missed.
And I missed.
I missed every shot.
Nice.
Me too.
I'm gonna smoke them.
It's too embarrassing now.
It's too embarrassing.
Wait, they're resing.
Wait, no!
I gave them a smoke so they can res!
Oh, that's another squad?
No!
I gave them a smoke for their fucking res!
That's...
We gotta go inside the lane.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where do we wanna go?
I don't know.
We gotta figure out soon.
Maybe we land over there?
Oh, sure.
We have to...
I'm smoking.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
We have to go then.
Okay, bye.
Ow!
Ow.
Ouch!
Okay, go here.
Nice, nice.
Oh, there's a team in front.
Do you guys have more syringes?
I have two.
I have four.
I can't give you one.
Okay, okay.
Be careful, because they're gonna have high ground.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm watching.
No!
They're fighting with another team.
Be careful!
Oh, I'm out.
Keg one.
Nice.
I'm looking above.
I'm gonna look above us.
Yeah.
They're fighting with another team.
I mean...
Maybe we can go to that building.
Okay, you guys.
I'm gonna look real fast.
If I die, I die.
Okay.
I'm gonna look real fast.
Okay, okay.
If I die, I die.
I believe in you two.
And I can watch you two play.
You can come here.
Goodbye!
I'm gonna break.
It's fine.
I'm good.
Go, go, go.
Okay.
This building.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go, go, go.
There's no one.
It's free.
Free.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm gonna move.
Wow!
They're fighting, too!
Crazy!
They're fucking...
Wait, there's people behind us.
Crazy.
They're fucking crazy.
House fighter, house fighter.
Where?
Ping.
Over there, over there, over there, over there.
They're going third.
Everyone left.
Everyone left the...
Yeah.
Everyone left us.
Everyone just wants to fucking fight this.
Everyone has energy.
Everyone wants to...
I will go to this house.
Yeah, we'll just cross.
I'm looking here.
Okay.
They're pushing?
Are they pushing?
On me!
Here!
Behind this.
On me!
They're pushing.
They're planning on pushing.
How many people?
Two teams.
One behind this box and one here.
Okay.
I'll give you a...
Pack one.
Careful of this box.
This box has a team too.
There's a guy right here.
Yeah, this guy can come.
Jesus.
What?
No!
Okay, they might push.
They might push.
Can you guys get a rez?
No, no, they're pushing.
No, no, no.
They're pushing.
Careful.
Okay.
They're full pushing.
Crack.
Oh, goodbye.
Goodbye, Ditto.
I got... What the fuck?
One, two, three, four, five headshots in a row.
Really?
Yeah!
From three different...
From two different people.
I was like, how did I die so fast?
Oh my god.
That's dumb.
Five different headshots.
That's...
Wow.
NG, NG.
Five headshots.
That's a lot.
Wow.
That is way too many headshots.
Oh my god.
Oh.
That's too much fun.
Oh my god, please.
Just... You know what?
Send it.
It's... Maybe I just need to be revved.
We won on rev.
Okay, okay.
Maybe I just need to be revved.
Yeah, right.
This is it.
Here we go.
We got this.
I can... I believe.
I believe.
We believe.
Yeah.
Wow.
We can win.
I believe in us.
Sure.
We can win.
You have to IGL us.
If you IGL us, you will win.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're just...
We're just missing your IGL.
Yeah.
Please IGL us.
It's all.
One team, one team.
They have like...
I don't know.
Passwader with default skin.
It's okay.
We can do this.
I believe.
I'm not scared.
Oh shit, I have a charm.
What happened?
Oh, what happened?
I'm gonna die.
Whoa.
No, you're not.
You're fine.
I'm watching.
They're running.
Okay, nice.
They're scared.
They saw you and they got scared.
Yeah.
When you're running away too.
You're so scary.
Oh, sorry.
What happened?
I thought you're better.
I'll help it up.
It's just me.
I have a charm.
I'm coming over.
Wait, what?
That charge rifle too.
Really?
I'm gonna push.
Whoa.
How dare you.
Here.
Over there.
So far, I think they help scope.
They have two snipers.
They have scope.
Yeah, they do.
They must have.
Okay.
Cool.
Oh, wait.
That's a window.
Nice shot.
Thank you.
Whoa.
They didn't scan me.
I'm ready to go whenever... Do we have gun?
Yeah.
I have a gun.
Waiting for the scan.
Oh, inside.
On me?
Yeah.
Okay.
Whoa.
Thank you.
Crack.
The guy on you.
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I'm buying.
Crack.
Crack him.
Nice.
I have to heal.
Thank you.
Oh, nice.
Last guy.
Nice.
Nice one.
Easy.
Did you just watch him run past you?
Yes.
I didn't see him until you told me.
I was like, what the fuck?
He's in front of you.
I didn't see him.
I wonder what's in the center now.
Now that there's no armor.
We have a...
I need a hemlock.
Hemlock?
Okay.
I need RE.
Nice.
Okay.
RE.
How?
A P20?
No.
Okay.
Absolutely not.
Not that.
RE.
Where are you?
I need that.
Okay.
I have... I have 4 battery.
If you want one, tell me.
2.
2 battery.
I need... I have 0.
I need a bat.
Yeah.
And here, one more.
If I have 30, 30, let me know.
Okay.
I'm like...
So poor.
Actually, no.
I have good guns, but...
I don't want to use these guns.
Okay.
Every time...
Every time I'm gonna give you a shield...
I always miss...
I always give it to Uto.
Wingman!
Wait, wait, wait.
Let's get Wingman.
Okay.
Landslide...
Be careful.
Landslide is looted.
I'm not scared.
I'm rev.
Alright.
Do you want the Wingman?
Uto?
Tuto?
No.
What happened?
You used to be so good at Wingman.
Wow.
What happened?
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Why don't you... Why don't you use it?
Okay, fine.
Okay, okay.
I'll use it.
I'll show you how it's done.
Okay.
Okay, I still need...
I have hemlock and bolt.
I have my favorite gun.
I need...
I still need...
RE.
I found an RE.
Oh, if you have RE...
Here, here, RE!
Nice.
Maybe...
Here, I dropped...
Nice, nice.
I dropped so many things.
Okay, nice.
This mine now.
Wait, I'm gonna...
I think I dropped a light mag.
I have a key.
Oh, are we gonna go to the...
Okay, yeah, yeah.
Let's go to the vault.
Let's just gear up.
Did I... Do I have a light mag?
Yeah, I did.
I'm coming over.
Alright.
Wait, the wingman doesn't have a digi anymore?
The fuck is this?
Really?
Wait.
Oh, there's people!
No!
Please!
Oh my god!
I'm giving up!
Nice!
Let's get the tiger's flag!
Okay, okay, okay, I'm leaving!
Run, run, run, run, run, run!
I'm gonna use my urn.
Yeah, yeah, run, run, run.
Nice, nice, nice.
Please, I just got my wingman!
Let me at least use it one time!
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push!
What the fuck?!
I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
I can't use my wingman!
Where did the iron hit me?
He didn't loot my body!
My wingman is still there!
I have the god loadout!
Are you fucking kidding me?
Dude, are you happy?
No!
What was this guy?
How can you call me?
No!
Dude, what the...
I lost my...
No!
I can't believe it!
I couldn't...
I couldn't even use it!
That's the worst part!
I don't even get to use it!
You have hammerpoint and you have wingman.
You have really, really good loot.
But...
Nice, Tana.
You have no chance to use this, unfortunately.
Oh my god.
Oh, such a bad timing.
Jun-sensei.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I can't...
Holy shit.
That was so unlucky.
Bro, fuck that team for six.
Why are you aiming in there?
Oh...
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
That was actually crazy.
Crazy.
Go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh my god.
F***.
No way.
There is no way.
We can't get champion.
We can, we can't.
Can.
We just got fucked over.
Don't stop believing.
One team, one team.
We will.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, i'm ready.
I'm gonna land here.
2 teams, 2 teams.
Cool team!
2 teams?
What happened?
Goodbye everybody.
Look at what's going on right now!
Woohoo!
I'm okay.
It's fine.
I have to keep on believing.
Don't stop believing.
I'm okay.
You're broken?
I'm broken.
Are you broken?
Okay.
That team that fucking crouched next to that cave?
That is so bullshit.
Oh, stop shooting me!
On the other side.
I'm okay.
I don't see anyone.
They're triple taking.
Where's the second team?
Where the fuck are you?
Don't stop believing.
Over there.
One guy there.
Where's there?
Here, here.
On the pink.
Oh, okay.
Anybody close?
They come up.
Wait, I thought there were two.
I don't know another team.
Maybe they went to Apex Center.
Maybe, yeah.
Okay, okay.
Do you have a loot?
No.
Oh, wait, I do.
I have gun.
Okay, do you want to fight?
Wait, is that a window?
I can't tell.
Yeah, that's a window.
That's a window.
I can't tell!
It's so far!
I don't have a scope!
Okay, I can go up.
Let's do it.
Are we gonna go?
Yes.
Okay.
You say if we kill them, we win, right?
I'm gonna go up.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Two here, two here, two here, two here.
I think I'm gonna die.
Where you doing?
Because they are gonna B me.
Why are you by yourself?
Okay, no!
I'm gonna die first, I guess!
I'm gonna die!
So, I think.
I think maybe we run.
I think...
There's another team behind us!
Ah!
Uto, hide!
Just hide, they're right here.
Don't let them get to you.
Oh, now they show up.
No!
What the f***?
I can't believe they just showed up behind us.
Where did they come from?
From behind.
Behind us?
Oh, there was another team.
I see.
The first team that... okay, Dylan, we start and Dylan.
Oh my god.
How unlucky are we?
You are lucky.
You are so lucky.
Oh my god.
Unfortunate.
So unfortunate.
Okay, this time, this game, this is it.
I believe.
There's no way.
Three times in a row unlucky?
Yes, there's no way.
There's no way.
Three times.
I've hit GB.
Oh.
Yeah, we have... we have...
Dome fight.
Oh, smart, smart.
This is it.
There's no way.
Three times in a row, no.
We're stronger now.
Yes, go, let's go.
There's...
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
This is it.
Go, go, go.
Okay.
Okay, we were always lucky on countdown.
Yey.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Countdown, we've always been lucky.
We always win the fights on countdown.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe two teams this time.
I'll go right side.
I'll go right.
I got gun.
I got gun too.
I got really good gun.
I'm gonna fight.
I have really good gun too.
Okay.
I will take our place.
They are over here.
I'm going with you.
Uto can flank.
We can fight.
This is it.
Over here.
Okay.
Nice.
They are charge rifle.
They have shit guns.
36.
Okay.
Their guns are shit.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
Whoa.
Careful.
Okay.
Are you sure?
Are you sure it's okay?
I don't feel okay anymore.
He's so low.
Oh they are all so low.
They are all low.
No.
Not
this.
No.
My first blood.
What's going on?
I think we got swapped.
You know the server is cursed.
The server is cursed.
Ditto.
Pick us another server.
This is a cursed server.
Cursed server.
I see.
Yeah.
We go find another server.
Which one?
Ditto.
Surprise us.
Surprise.
Your server?
My server?
Okay.
Alright.
We'll use my server.
Okay.
Which one?
I will join.
Yeah.
You join me.
Okay.
Yeah.
Come here.
I can't join.
Alright.
I want you.
This is it.
Alright.
Here we go.
Okay.
Alright.
This is it.
We're not cursed.
We can't be cursed anymore.
We can't be cursed.
This changes everything.
Oh my god.
There's so little people in the ring.
What the fuck?
Where are you guys?
Fifteen people.
Why is there fifteen people?
It's the prime time ring.
Every hour is prime time.
What time is it now?
It's like 1143.
Gamers don't sleep.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Guys.
Gamers do not sleep.
And because gamers do not sleep, every hour is prime time.
I see.
Yeah.
Every hour people play ranked.
There's no such thing as downtime.
The season literally came out two days ago.
People will still be grinding.
So fast.
I wish you were a rookie.
So why are you on his face?
It's my fault.
Too many people grinded.
Ranking.
This is it.
It's gonna be different now.
Ah fuck.
Okay.
No, don't worry.
It'll be different.
It's not that different.
It'll be so different.
Trust.
Same spot.
Okay.
Count down.
We never lose countdown except last game.
No.
We never lose.
I was lagging.
Yeah.
Now you're gonna be lagging even more.
One team.
One team?
Oh yeah.
Above us.
Yeah.
They are landing far.
We can land close.
I land here.
One guy near me.
But I can't... I'm gonna go kill him.
Okay, you're gonna go kill him?
What if you don't kill him?
Missed kick.
I'm making a kayak.
Coming over.
Okay, I got power and nemesis.
Nice.
You want us to come over?
Over there?
I'm gonna craft the bat real fast.
I'm gonna head from... I'm heading this side.
I'm going right side.
Whoa!
Careful!
Don't die.
Coming over.
Go go!
Whoa!
Are they pushing you or no?
No, not yet.
Okay.
They're still inside.
I'm looking for you.
They're pushing!
They're pushing you!
Okay.
We're coming over.
Whoa!
Try to cover.
Kill him!
Nice!
Only two.
Let me know they're res.
Let me know they're resing.
They're resing.
Okay.
Go!
Nice one.
Last one?
Last one.
Nice!
Look!
We never lose countdown!
Wow!
Easy peasy.
We never lose countdown.
I told you.
We lose countdown.
Yeah.
What?
They always...
They always push GB.
Why?
Cuz you're big and fat.
They're like...
They're like, look at you.
So juicy!
Yeah.
Skyhook I hear.
I want to check over Skyhook.
Are you going to go third?
Yeah, let's go third.
Okay.
They have nothing.
They only have one area.
Can you open up for me?
Yeah, I'll go scout.
I'll scout.
Okay, you go scout.
Never lose countdown.
Okay, I will use speed fire.
I'm trying to figure out where they are.
I don't see them.
I don't know if they finished?
Finished?
Oh, army?
Okay.
Going, going.
Yeah, yeah, they are behind.
No, no, that's why.
Fuck.
Okay, I'm backing up.
Backing up.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, you don't need to.
Never mind.
Cover us.
Solo 100 on...
Get the fuck... Okay.
Oh my god.
Shit.
Chill.
Oh my god.
He cabin.
I see.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Fuck.
I'm low.
Oh, I'm dead.
No!
Holy shit.
You got... You got like...
You got beamed so fast.
I got beamed because I'm fat.
Okay.
Wait, why you not get me?
Wait, wait, wait.
I know.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna play Kha'Zix.
You play Rev.
This is it.
This is the comp.
Why?
I believe in you.
No, no.
No, I believe in you.
I believe in you and Rev.
I believe in you.
You're so good at Rev.
I...
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You got... I believe in you so hard.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
You can do this.
Why?
This is it.
I swear.
Your Rev is gonna be so hot.
Okay.
Wait, Utho, no!
Utho, no!
No!
Oh, no!
Okay, it's okay.
We can leave this.
Oh, no.
Wait.
I think she still can connect.
No, I don't think so.
If she can't connect by...
Oh, nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh.
It'll be different.
I swear.
Oh.
I believe.
Okay.
For the first time, I'll jump.
We'll do here.
This is a good spot.
Trust.
One body.
Wait, is it one?
Two.
Three.
Three?
Okay, I'm landing here.
That is way too many.
Wait, we're contested.
What the fuck?
They come with us.
Yeah, yeah.
They contested us.
You're by yourself.
I don't have any gun.
Come to us.
Jump to us.
I can kill you.
You're fine.
Oh, the fuck.
I don't have anything.
I cracked one.
Nice one.
I cracked the other.
Okay.
Okay, I will go with punch.
What the fuck?
Okay, okay.
They're scared of pushing right now.
What the fuck?
We can back up.
Back up.
I have a gun.
You have a gun?
Okay, okay.
Then we can fight this.
I want to just back up.
Okay.
They don't have...
They should not have...
They don't have enough heals to fight us because I cracked them like three times.
Yeah, okay.
I cracked them again.
Wait, I might be able to crack them again.
Yeah, I'll give you...
They have casting.
I'll give you.
Yeah, but they should have heals because I cracked them so many times.
There's no way Wait, they found enough shield cells.
Are they still inside?
Yeah.
Are they?
No!
Oh, they left.
Yeah, bitch!
What?
Alright, let's loot.
Let's loot.
Okay.
Stupid.
Okay, okay.
Let's go loot that.
That's right.
This is what happens when I have...
30 ping.
Or 60 ping.
Alright.
Did they finish shooting each other?
Okay.
I'm gonna go with you, Ditto.
No one with me.
Yeah, no one...
It's not like, fucking double A.
Oh, right here.
Light magazine.
Oh, nice.
Enemy?
Yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, yeah.
He's so, so close.
So close.
What?
Really?
Where?
On my left.
Here.
Oh, no.
Behind.
He followed me.
I'm looking.
I cack one.
Solo.
Okay, I got you.
Let me...
We can push this guy.
He's by himself.
Okay.
I'll cover you guys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
His teammates are so far.
His teammates are really far.
You guys push him.
He's high.
I'll cover.
They're coming.
Come back.
Ditto.
The teammates are here.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Flash.
MadMaggie1.
Okay.
Okay, I'm looking.
I'm covering.
Careful, Ditto.
There's a cool heal.
I can cover from outside here.
I don't have...
Oh, okay.
That's bad.
Jump to me.
I can Q you.
Okay.
I have cells.
So you can jump to me.
Oh.
He's so low.
Yeah.
Jump to me.
You're low.
You guys don't have heals.
I have...
No cell here.
I dropped two for you.
They're getting...
I have Q and 3.
Oh, he's so low.
They're all so low.
Oh, I can't give you the Q.
There's a guy right here.
Oh no, Ditto, your spy is down.
Ditto, no!
Ditto, he's so low!
Leave, leave, leave.
Good Ditto, that's three people!
That's three people!
You're crazy!
I love cheap people!
I don't have any magazine.
Oh my god, you're insane.
You try to win.
Oh my god, Utho is so poor right now.
She's starving.
Are you fucking... Oh my god!
They're redeployed.
Holy shit.
We don't have another redeploy though.
Oh, and I dropped my Phoenix Kit for you too.
I can't even craft you because they're chasing us.
Okay, there's only one.
There's only one thing I can do.
And it's this.
Boom.
I don't know if I'll hit.
Okay, the best... Okay.
Are you... Deadslide.
Ah, Deadslide!
Deadslide.
Go!
Live for us!
Live!
Oh wait, no, don't come to me.
No!
I said live!
I said...
No!
No, I got Deadslide again!
Jesus Christ.
I don't know.
I said live.
What happened to living?
You can save us, right?
I don't know.
This... This doesn't look very hopeful right now.
I literally...
I literally have not a lot of resources.
Alright.
You can do it.
Okay.
Alright.
You can do it.
You think they're gonna count me?
Let's find out!
Woah...
But I've been down.
I think there's still cause to us.
Alright, it's either I do this or I die.
Here we go.
Wait!
Wait, wait, wait.
First step, first step, first step.
Well, this is my last skill.
I know, I forgot.
What the heck?
How come you forgot?
Because you said footsteps!
So I panicked.
I was like, I heard footsteps?
And then I freaked out.
They are gone.
Nice signing.
One.
Better than nothing.
That's true.
Alright, Okay, let's up here.
Look how far!
Oh my god.
I think we're gonna die.
We're gonna die.
We're gonna die in zone.
We are not.
Believe?
Okay, okay, we will not die in zone.
We will not.
We won't.
Look how far the zone is.
What do you mean?
It's okay, I'm a Pathfinder.
You're right!
I have a slut.
Oh, I forgot.
What do you mean?
I'm Pathfinder.
I'm not Pathfinder.
I thought everyone was paying for Pathfinder.
Don't worry, I'm Pathfinder.
That makes me worry even more because you said I'm Pathfinder.
Why?
You guys better hurry.
This zone.
Okay.
Oh no.
I feel like we are gonna get championed in this match.
I feel like somebody's gonna camp us right at this edge.
I can feel it.
I can feel that one team just waiting at the edge.
No, no, I don't feel it.
I feel it.
I feel it in my bones right now.
I can smell it too.
I feel it right now.
Okay.
We will see.
Okay, I'm seeing.
I'm seeing.
No, they're fighting each other.
They have no time for us.
They're too busy.
Maybe we can get into that building.
Alright.
Let's go.
I swear to god if...
I swear to god.
Oh, that's...
This has been...
This has been a very scuffed game.
Oh, we got...
We got inside the lane.
Oh my god.
One team so close.
Okay.
I'm trying to grab...
Have a point.
One more point.
Okay, I don't think I should bring it.
Have a point.
You should get it.
I don't have...
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Yeah, just take it.
Hold on to it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
I'm going to you.
There's so many people fighting around us.
I'm so scared.
Oh!
I'm gonna craft.
Nice.
I'll craft too.
We have craft.
You can...
You can?
Here we go.
How can you craft it?
You craft banner once.
No, each...
Each machine is one.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah.
It's not one whole game.
Oh, I thought no.
Wait, you didn't know?
I didn't know.
You didn't try to craft more?
I didn't try to craft more.
You tried.
You only did one.
I don't know.
Maybe this is why we didn't craft more.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I saw, I saw.
Wait, Forest?
Maybe this is why we didn't start getting...
Solo.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's solo.
Come on, feed us.
Feed us.
Okay, I'm gonna...
Okay, okay, I cracked him.
Yes, he's cracked.
He's cracked.
Okay, I'm going.
Go, go, go!
No, no, I cracked him.
Please kill him.
I want this!
Goodbye.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
I know one, I know one.
Only one here.
Oh no, it's a full team.
It's a full team.
No, yeah, it's a full team.
Holy shit.
I thought like, um...
Levernance.
But you down one!
But you down one.
What happened?
I don't know how to jump!
I don't know... I'm just playing.
There was a full team behind us that jumped after you.
Really?
I didn't think that.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
Can I craft anything?
We have to find another one.
No, we don't have it.
There's no other one.
The only one is here.
Do you have a cell?
No!
Wait, let me use this.
It's important!
It's so important!
You're gonna get us champion, right?
Alright.
I'm gonna leave.
What the fuck is that?
What?
I didn't need that battery.
I did not need it.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, this is going to be awkward.
Guys, I don't know what to do.
I don't know.
I don't think we're gonna get champion.
It's okay.
We can do it.
Don't give up.
Just don't stop believing.
Don't stop.
Like you said.
You win.
Okay.
Don't stop believing.
They don't see.
Go here.
Don't stop believing.
Woah.
They don't see.
Oh my god.
Why did they turn around?
Where did you come from?
Okay.
What the fuck?
I feel like...
I feel like bad game.
That game we just played.
I don't know.
I didn't think we were gonna win that game.
Let's communicate.
Okay.
Communicate.
If you tell me go, I go.
If you tell me fall back, I'll back.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh.
I know why.
Okay.
I know.
Because I have 200 bing.
Okay.
I will play more safe.
More safe.
Ah.
Champion.
Basement until champion.
Champon.
Champon this.
I haven't...
I haven't ate breakfast yet.
And it's 3pm now.
Me too.
So fast.
It's 3pm now.
5pm now.
Yo.
So... Yes.
Yes.
Hungry.
No.
No eat.
Hungry.
No champion.
No food.
No sleep.
Why is the voice so small?
It's small, right?
It's so close.
Suddenly it's close.
Eh?
Yeah.
It's close.
Okay.
I will play Baton.
See you.
Baton.
I'm back.
Who needs to eat?
Um.
There's no one needs to eat.
Good.
Oh.
Only play.
Only winners eat.
Until we win the game.
Okay.
Only winners eat.
Yeah.
Uto Uto said that she was hungry.
But she didn't need to eat.
Oh.
Eat and play.
Yes.
That's why we have two hands.
Two hands.
Don't-don't you have two hands too?
Yeah.
But I'm not hungry.
I already ate.
I can't-I can't play until we got the champion.
Hello.
We got this.
Champion.
This is it.
I believe!
We just need to find the perfect comp!
Just keep believing!
Just believe!
I believe.
I believe I can fly.
Me too.
But you can't fly because you are a bird.
Yeah, exactly.
I believe.
I don't even need to believe, I know it's a fact.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
You're right.
It's your turn.
Okay, okay, okay.
Go here!
This is our champion spot!
Our champion spot!
I agree!
I believe!
There's no one coming with us!
See?
Oh my god!
We are champions!
There's no one gonna steal our loot!
I hope so.
I'm double checking.
I'm scared.
No, no, no.
Let it go.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
I thought... I was scared you'll lie to me.
No.
I'm not... Oh my god.
I'm not lying.
Alright, here we go.
Oh yeah, remember when you said you heard people over here?
Remember that?
Do you remember?
That's sad.
Yeah, wasn't that a lie?
No!
That's true.
And where did the person go?
I think they left the game.
Yeah?
Oh, they left the game.
Where was his box?
Oh, maybe they're cheater and they were trying to kill you and they got banned.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where was the box?
Because you couldn't find it.
The box is somewhere.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I couldn't find it.
It just disappeared.
Yes.
Wow, so spooky.
I need a repeater.
Okay.
Okay, I got Nemesis and R9.
R9 again.
I have Hemlock and R9, but I want a repeater.
Nemesis here.
Okay, I'm good.
I need Hemlock.
Oh, not Hemlock.
R3030.
Okay.
Where am I?
Oh, I want that.
Oh, I did it.
I'm gonna grab the ball, actually.
Prowler?
Nice one.
Where is the 3030?
I'll ping you if I find it.
3030.
Does anyone need bats?
I have six.
I have two.
Okay.
Oops, that's not right.
I dropped two.
Ball bat.
Okay.
I got it.
If anyone...
I have... I want scope.
Oh, I have scope, but it's my scope.
Oh, Nemesis.
Okay.
If someone ping me...
I just wanted you to know.
Okay.
All right, Uto.
Uto, you're gonna kill 10 people, okay?
10 people?
10 people, yes.
Yes, yes.
You kill 10 people, and then we win champion.
Okay.
That's it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I believe in you.
If you don't kill 10 people...
Uh-oh.
I need mid-chain.
I'll report you.
Okay, okay.
I'll report you for...
I'm 10 people killed.
...for creeping my game.
Oh my god.
You don't want me to report you.
I have six now.
There's more bats here.
A lot.
I don't need it.
I need to...
Hi.
Okay, each kill you get...
Uto, each kill...
you get...
you can eat one...
you can have one bite of food.
Really?
Yeah.
Like, yeah.
Oh my god.
What is this game?
It's like a...
like a dog.
Like, you know, you're training a dog.
No, don't kill me.
This game is like a dog.
I'm a dog.
Oh my god.
How does it change a painting?
Just make...
Just make a paint and it's...
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
What?
Don't you have dog ears?
One kill, one bite.
Oh my god.
Here's a scope.
It's called positive reinforcement.
It's...
I'm rewarding her.
She gets to eat.
What?
Enemy?
What happened?
What was that?
I heard a slide.
In here?
No.
Yeah.
Enemy, enemy, enemy.
Okay, okay.
I'm pushing.
I'm right behind you.
Uto, go.
Go.
Okay, okay.
Go, go.
Wait, where did you...
I'm here.
Okay.
Inside?
Scan?
No.
Where the fuck did they go?
I heard...
I heard something.
I'm here.
Okay.
Remember last time you heard something?
I heard something.
Okay.
The scan!
Yeah, you heard something.
I love this song!
There's people here.
Where's Flandre?
Oh, in front of me, in front of me, in front of me.
Go, go, go, go.
Wow!
Here in front.
Two teams, two teams, two teams.
Where am I?
The fuck is going on?
Two, two, one, two, two, one, one.
Okay, one!
Yeah.
Are they fighting each other?
Here they are.
There's like a team in that building.
Okay, I will scan.
Okay.
One.
Why?
They move so fast.
Oh, wait, here.
Wow!
That's a different team.
I'm still like holding on to like...
I'm not a good team.
Yeah.
I remember when you heard something, Ditto.
Over there, over there, over there.
Holyo, Holyo.
Yeah.
Helping you.
High ground, they're high ground now.
I'm gonna come to you.
There's people in front.
There's people here.
Okay, I'm gonna scan.
Next building.
No one in next building.
I'm tracking tracks.
I see people in train.
Not train, uh...
Steamer.
Steamer building.
Okay.
Whoa!
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck?
Yeah, he fucked me up.
Oh.
Alright, I need heal.
Is that Sniper?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sniper and 30-30.
They're not...
This team really wants to kill me.
I'm going over to you guys.
Behind, behind.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to you, Ditto.
Okay.
I'm good, I'm good.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Behind the two teams.
I want to fight with my aim.
20...
There's like a...
They're like all so far.
They're so far.
Yeah.
Everybody's just running away from each other.
So we can't really do anything.
Yeah.
They keep running.
They're all so scared.
Come on!
Which one needs to eat?
I'm going to kill!
Hungry, hungry.
Okay.
There is...
They're all just poking each other.
They're not fighting at all.
Wait, wait.
Yeah, they're fighting here too.
They're fighting here.
Okay.
What?
Pushing up.
I'm using my ult.
They're really far, Ditto.
Okay.
I went there, I went there.
I'm so far.
I'm using my ult.
They're so long.
Kind of long.
I'm going to go get anchor.
Here, here.
In front of me.
I thirsted, I thirsted.
Okay, Ditto.
You're by yourself.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
I'm here, I'm here.
Got you.
Nice.
I got the bat.
I thirsted for you.
There's another team behind me.
They are?
Where?
I see them, I see them.
Careful, careful.
One is K.
See her?
Oh my god.
Wait, behind me.
See her, 100.
Oh, sorry.
Got one, I got one.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Can you come talk to me?
I got the bat.
I got to you, I got to you.
Maybe he's batting.
He's batting.
Okay.
Oh no.
I got scanned.
Another team.
Fuck.
Oh shit.
Okay, here, here.
Yeah, but there he is.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where is she?
Oh my god.
You might have a bullet.
Wait, it's two teams.
And they shot at me.
It was two teams.
They both shot at me.
Oh my god.
Okay, Uto.
How many kills did you get, Uto?
Okay.
How many kills, Uto, did you get?
How many kills?
Zero, zero.
No bite.
How many kills did I get?
Oh, I got zero too, so...
I'm...
Only Ditto can eat.
Why?
Wait, did you get one kill?
I get... I get one knock.
Oh, one knock, no bite.
I get one kill.
You can have one bite.
One bite.
Can I stack my bite?
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
No stacking.
It's... It's training.
We're all training.
We're here to train.
Oh my god.
What a chain.
What chain?
Champion.
We're training for champion.
Oh, I see.
Yeah.
I almost forgot.
You almost forgot?
That's the reason why we haven't stopped.
What do you mean?
I have to...
order some food first.
We can do this.
Okay.
What are you gonna eat, Uta?
Hm?
What are you gonna eat?
Gohan.
Kills.
She's gonna eat kills.
Gohan?
Okay.
Yeah, I'm landing here.
Do we have team?
Oh, we have team.
Yeah, we have team.
That's Mirage.
That's stupid.
That is all fake.
But I hear... I hear people.
Oh no, no.
It's still Mirage.
Yes.
Did you say that's stupid?
Who said that?
Yeah, that's stupid.
Stupid.
There's a lot of people.
I'm scared.
I got the gap.
Wow!
Hello.
Are you okay?
Yeah.
We're fine.
We're so healthy.
This is two teams.
Two teams?
Two, two, two.
I have a sentinel.
Okay.
What the fuck?
I'm good.
Okay.
Do you have light?
Oh, I hear them.
They're still fighting.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow.
Oh.
I got scanned?
Oh, knock, knock.
I hear knocks.
Hmm.
Nice.
Above us?
Yeah.
I'm gonna heal.
Okay.
Where are you?
I am here.
Hmm.
Oh, shit.
Where are you?
They're shooting her from high ground.
Okay.
They're still fighting.
I'm gonna wait a bit.
I got scanned.
Okay.
Push.
I cracked one.
Cracked bloodhound.
Careful, careful.
The other...
The condom might drop on you.
Where's Bloodhound?
I don't know.
I didn't... I don't know where he ran to.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's...
It fucked up everything.
I'm getting...
I thirsted.
Okay.
I got thirst.
One down.
Drop to me.
Careful.
One down.
I can...
What the fuck?
What the...
I thirsted.
One bike.
Okay.
Cover me.
Where's...
Where's the cover?
Oh.
Did I not say cover?
Yeah.
Cover me.
I don't know where they are.
Where are they?
I don't know.
I hear two.
It's two.
Through here.
Running.
Yeah.
I'm gonna go, Rez.
I don't know!
You get one bite!
I also have one bite.
Oh my god!
I'm hungry!
You can have one bite!
One bite of whatever food you want.
One bite.
I'm hungry!
Okay, but that grapple was funny.
I fucked my Gabo two times.
And the same place.
I don't know where he ran to.
He ulted and disappeared.
Wherever he is.
I think they're gonna go...
Yeah, I think so too.
We can loot then.
Oh yeah!
We won!
Okay.
I got it.
We did it!
Yay!
I'm gonna run double heavy.
Nice!
I will just Hemlock and Root.
Yeah, I'm using Hemlock Prowler.
How far?
Oh, it's not that far.
The zone.
It's not that far yet.
Yeah, yeah.
Let me find repeater.
Oh, they're reviving!
They are?
I'm too lazy.
They can live.
Let's go.
Yay!
Oh, this is looted.
Just looted.
Um, the armor.
Oh yeah, it's just the white armor.
So, I'm trying to find a 30.
Yay!
Oh, thank you.
You guys need bats?
I have four.
I have two.
Look at how many...
Oh, here.
I'll give one.
Thank you.
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna open this crate.
Okay.
Oh.
More bats.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah.
There's two extra here.
And...
Two back two.
I have...
I need a scope.
Um, which scope?
Uh...
Two, three, or four.
Oh my god!
Hammer point!
I'm gonna grab it.
Light mag.
Yeah.
Uh...
Okay.
Did you just grab...
Um, 20-20?
Yeah, but I'm gonna try to find a...
Okay.
R.E.
R.E.?
Yeah, I just wanted to put it on my gun first.
I need R.E.
Oh, I'm trying to count.
Okay.
R.E.?
Yeah.
Okay.
This is it.
We believe!
We need R.E.
Please.
Okay, let's go to zone.
Let's just slowly head to zone.
Alright.
Where is zone gonna end?
Um, Skyhook.
Okay, let's go to Skyhook.
Okay, okay.
Oh my god, I see your syringes.
If you see extra health...
That's not good.
I believe.
We need to keep believing.
Oh, one team landed.
They're flying to Skyhook.
I mean...
We could just walk, honestly.
Okay.
I don't think we need to redeploy.
We can just walk over.
I don't see them.
I bet...
Ditto, you're gonna run into three men and die.
I knew it.
Okay, Uto, Uto.
Go in front.
This time, we go together.
No, no, no.
Uto goes in front.
Uto defends us.
Okay.
I want that.
What?
You see someone?
No.
Armor, armor.
No, we don't need it.
We don't need it.
We're strong.
Okay, I believe you.
Yeah, believe in me.
If we die, it's not my fault.
It's not my fault if we die.
Believe.
Gotta believe.
We just gotta keep believing.
The reason why we keep dying is because we stop believing.
I believe.
Maybe I think I have never believed it at first.
You didn't believe!
What's wrong?
No, I'm believing.
Okay, okay, okay.
Is this why we're still playing?
I feel like that's a pro team.
The Horizon Octane.
Because usually pro teams...
Or like, not pro team, but like...
Pred team?
Pred teams, they put...
They put streamer mode.
Okay.
I see.
Did you get RE?
I got it, I got it.
I found one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Majority of streamers put streamer mode on.
Because they don't want to get sniped.
I mean, which is obvious.
Whoa!
Wait.
Oh my god, there's...
There's a lot.
Wait, you... Okay, you can't...
You can't have it.
Me?
Okay, but I have RE.
Oh, really?
Hmm?
Is that...
Is EVA 8 good?
Yeah, EVA 8 is broken.
Okay.
Someone needs to get it.
Because it's actually strong.
Yeah, EVA 8 very strong.
Oh no!
Um, wait.
I think it's... it's taken.
What?
No, no, it's right here.
Right here?
No, it's in the box.
Right here.
This box?
Yeah.
Okay.
No one took it.
Oh my god.
Um...
Uh...
Believe!
Okay, believe!
Why are you not believing?
Ditto.
Okay, believe, believe.
Okay, I'm believing.
Okay, good.
I'm using this right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep believing!
Wait, they're rezzing.
Another team here too.
I think we can wait a little bit.
Team here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, they're... someone's pushing them.
Cracked the horizon?
Oh, so low!
Very low!
Nice!
Nice.
Push?
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Push, push, push, push!
Two-point!
Go, go, go, go!
Oh my god!
Oh, my...
Oh, we got the kill!
We got the kill!
Careful, careful!
I don't think we...
Another team!
Another team?
Okay, okay.
Careful, Ditto!
Ditto, Ditto, Ditto!
I don't have Q!
Another team!
Okay.
I have Q!
Baby, come to me!
Come to me!
Come to me, Ditto!
Fall back!
Okay, okay.
Okay, go back!
Fall back, fall back, cause there's a...
Okay, okay.
I'm back, I'm back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can...
go on the outside, I feel like.
Actually, we can...
Where do we go?
Inside the building!
Yeah, yeah.
Do you want to go outside?
I got the bat!
I got the bat first!
We can stay here.
We can go here.
Stay here for now.
I don't want to go...
there, cause I feel like everybody should shoot us there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
There's one team have duel.
Only duel.
Okay.
I'm gonna charge my ult.
Alright.
I have ult.
Whoa!
Careful!
Wow!
I'm gonna check our backs.
There might be someone in the tunnel.
Okay.
I'm double checking.
Safe, safe.
Oh, so close!
Whoa!
Okay, I have Kraber!
I have Kraber!
Oh!
I don't have Q.
Good luck.
It's okay.
I'm good, I'm good.
But I don't have medkit.
I have medkit, I have medkit.
Here.
Okay.
I got you.
We gotta figure out where to go.
I think we gotta portal.
Maybe?
Hmm?
What Kraber?
Portal to here?
Mm-hmm.
Where do they go?
Wait, where are they going?
Oh, wait.
They're jumping far.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go this way.
We don't need portal, we can just walk.
Oh my god, there's...
It's getting scary.
I have eight!
I still have no repeater!
Oh, there it is.
I found one.
Found the repeater.
We need to get to...
Um...
We can go here too.
Wait, that's not zone, sorry.
Oh, no, sorry, here.
No.
Are we outskirts?
Do you wanna try out?
Or... I feel like here is better.
Okay.
There's no one here.
Yeah, there's no one here.
They're fighting at market.
Okay.
And there's people...
I'm trying to look right now.
What?
I can't see them.
Oh, here?
Octane over here.
Okay.
I don't have an angle.
I'll go there.
Okay.
Uh...
He saw me!
Alright, I'm gonna get cross.
Oh my god, I wish I had a sniper stock.
Come market, come market!
Won't you at market?
So much harder with no sniper stock.
Can we go there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's enemies.
I'm safe here too.
Okay.
I just wanna... I'll stay here for now for a cross.
Mhm.
Are they here?
I don't know where... I think they're here.
the other team is.
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey!
Is that right?
Behind.
Oh, the high ground team.
I think we have to go...
Ah!
Shit!
Oh my god!
Ah!
Okay.
I think we should go under, right?
Do we portal?
Um...
For it?
Maybe?
I don't have portal.
Like Uto.
Uto has portal.
Oh, Uto.
Okay.
Uto, can you?
Can you...
Uto, portal...
Maybe portal under?
Portal under.
Okay.
I believe in you.
Fuck that.
Whoever made that fucking...
cover... light flash.
We got her.
Is it safe?
Safe, safe.
We got the goal!
Oh shit!
Damn!
Yes!
Oh, the flag.
Careful, careful.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna bat.
Okay.
Oh, hold.
Kraber over here.
Yeah.
Safe here too.
Safe here.
Okay.
Yeah.
If we need to, we can...
They come here!
Lace!
Nice!
Kill, kill, kill.
This is safe too.
Where I am.
Okay.
Is there a sniper stock in there?
Can you check?
Can you check if sniper stock?
Sniper?
Sniper stock.
I don't know.
Okay.
Can you check real fast?
Yeah, yeah.
I need sniper stock.
I need this.
Um... No, no, no, no.
Okay.
Don't have it.
I think it's like a team here and then above us.
Yeah.
The Kraber team.
Kraber here.
Oh, no, no.
We killed the Kraber team.
Oh, you killed Kraber?
Yeah, there's no Kraber team.
Okay.
The team above us.
The team above us has...
I mean, I can...
I can...
I can alt the center.
Where is the center?
Let's move here.
Yeah.
I have to alt this.
Oh, my God.
Oh...
Where is the other team?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
On the ramp.
They're on the ramp.
And then the other team's above us.
Woah!
I really can't hear you.
Don't stop believing.
Ba da da da da da da da.
You can't stop believing!
I have four R stars.
We can't stop!
Oh, f**k you.
Oh, wait, here, here, here.
Can I go on?
Shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot it, shoot it!
Oh my
god!
Oh, sorry.
I got, I got...
Oh, I'm f**ked.
They're fighting each other.
They're fighting me?
Oh, damn!
Live, Oto!
Live!
I'll let you know, I'll let you know!
I'll let you know!
What?
That's one guy left!
That's one guy!
It's one guy!
I'm blocking him!
We did it!
I'm talking easy!
Oh my god.
We did it!
Oh, how proud of you!
All right!
Oh my god.
Oto, MVP.
MVP, Oto.
Yay!
Yeah!
GG's!
That was fun.
Thank you!
Ciao!
Oh my god.
That was really fun.
GG's guys.
Thank you for playing with me.
Thank you!
Goodnight, goodnight!
Goodnight everybody!
Have a nice...
Have nice lunch dinner.
Okay, okay.
GG's.
Thank you for playing!
Yeah, thank you for playing!
I had so much fun.
Baby time!
Yeah, thank you!
I'll see you guys.
Bye!
See you guys!
Bye bye!
Bye!
Oh my god.
Well that was...
That was such a...
I did not expect to have such a long session!
It just was really fun.
It was...
It was very, very fun.
I enjoyed playing it with...
Playing it with...
Uto and Ditto.
I always enjoyed playing with them.
Yes, please check them out.
They've always been good friends of mine.
Yeah.
And...
Always enjoyed playing Apex with both of them.
But yes!
I saw so many membership!
I'm so sorry!
I didn't thank all of you guys while I was playing!
Usually, like, when I'm in a collab, I try to, like, focus on the collab.
Like, just interacting with people.
So, I'm so sorry.
But thank you, everybody!
I saw so many 50 gifted ships!
It was crazy!
Beats, thank you for the 50 gifted ships!
Thank you!
And thank you all for the super chat!
I hope you guys had a lot of fun!
It was a very long session, so I...
It was also a very long VOD.
So, I hope you guys had fun watching.
I really did enjoy playing with the both of them.
Tomorrow is also another collab with Yuuson with Inside the Backrooms.
So, yeah!
I'm gonna enjoy playing that as well!
Thank you, everybody!
I am gonna pass out now.
I'm so tired.
Okay, I didn't tell you guys.
But I woke up at, like, 5 in the morning.
And I've been awake since!
I've been awake!
So, yeah!
My sleep schedule still hasn't been fixed yet.
But we had a fun time watching!
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed!
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody!
Bye, guys!
Bye!